[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay and we
have another great show for you today in
fact we are doing our very first
interview episode with this current
hosting lineup uh and we're excited to
welcome Beth sarei onto the podcast
today uh Beth is the health editor at
life haacker and a certified personal
trainer she's also the author of two
books genetics 101 from chromosomes and
the double helix to cloning and DNA
tests everything you need to know about
genes and outbreak 50 Tales of epidemics
that terrorize the world she's also a
accomplished practitioner of the odd
lfts which I think is very cool um she
competes in the usawa which is the US
allaround weightlifting Association and
has a record 510 lb Denny deadlift uh
and if you don't know what that is I can
put the the video of that in the show
notes it is extremely impressive um and
I've already told Beth this but uh just
on a personal level she is one of my
very favorite health and science writers
so I'm thrilled to be sharing a
conversation with her on the show today
uh so Beth welcome to the show thank you
I'm glad to be here and I'm a long time
fan of Stronger by science so this is
very exciting for me too thank you okay
so when I reached out about you coming
on the show um just just as a little
background for listeners um I I've been
following Beth's writing for a long time
and I saw she she mentioned on Reddit
that uh she was interested in maybe
starting a podcast so I was like hey you
know that's that's a lot of effort would
you have any interest in just coming on
ours instead and yeah I I trust her work
enough that I was willing to just say
like hey is there anything you want to
talk about that you think would be cool
one of the topics she brought up was
cortisol and it seems to be a pretty
intriguing And Timely topic because it's
it's a subject that's been blowing up on
social media recently uh in particular
Tik Tok uh and there seems to be a lot
of of interesting claims to put it a
politely or just blatant misinformation
to put it more directly um so yeah I I
thought that that would be a good topic
to discuss yeah before we get into all
those crazy claims though uh let's talk
about what cortisol actually is sure so
um yeah so I've been looking at a lot of
Tik Tok like Health misinformation for
and writing about it at work and
cortisol is coming up a lot um and it's
very often given as like this sort of
like this piy explanation about like
here's this here's the reason for all of
the problems that you're having in your
life and here's sometimes they tell you
what to do about it and sometimes they
don't usually what to do about it is to
like follow the link in their bio to buy
their supplements um of course but
cortisol is a real hormone um that is
involved in our body's response to
stress and there really are disorders
where it can be disregulated so um so to
get to get into what cortisol actually
is um because I think maybe not a lot of
these Tik tokers really actually know
they're they're repeating things that
they've heard that sound kind of good
and then kind of mixing and matching
with whatever it is they'd like to say
so and it and it's not just Tik Tok like
I'm going to pick on Tik Tok because I
spent a while like scrolling through
some of these Tik toks and sort of like
collecting examples of things that they
were saying but um like all the social
platforms kind of blend together like
somebody will take a a a video from Tik
Tok and post it in a reel on Instagram
and then somebody will show up on Reddit
asking about something they heard on
YouTube and um so it's just one giant
mess um that's going to be very fun to
sort through and people just share the
same content on multiple platforms just
every social media platform is a short
form vertical video site now so yeah
people post one thing on Tik Tok and
just share it everywhere yeah and
they're all they're all stealing each
other's format so like Tik Tok or
Instagram became Snapchat and you know
Twitter has Clubhouse and I don't know
whatever but um the the other funny
thing um not to digress too much the
other funny thing is that a like any
health myth that has ever existed is on
Tik Tok so like you can take something
that people were saying a hundred years
ago in that has been like thoroughly
debunked 100 years ago and just look it
up on Tik Tok and they're on Tik Tok
telling you why this is the sort like
this is how you're going to snatch your
waist today so oh my my gosh so so let's
get into cortisol itself okay so
cortisol is a hormone that's made by the
adrenal gland and so your I I find the
atmology of this kind of interesting so
your your adrenal glands are located on
top of your kidneys so ad renal meaning
on the kidney in
Latin and so adrenaline is one of the
hormones they produce so adrenaline from
the adrenal gland um and but we actually
like medically we call that hormone
epinephrine this is not cortisol
different hormone but um I I learned
today why why there are two different
names for it so in in England in the UK
they even medically they call it
adrenaline but here it's like
colloquially adrenaline and medically we
talk about epinephrine and
norepinephrine and it turns out that's
because the first person to make and
market a I don't know if you marketed it
but the first person to make an extract
of the adrenal gland that was supposed
to contain this stuff he called it
epinephrine because it means the same
thing Epi nephron means on top of the
kidney that's just the Greek instead of
the Latin and so he he thought Greek
sounded better he marketed this thing or
or studied it or whatever and it didn't
work he just up the extraction
there was no adrenaline or repine in it
um meanwhile somebody else did it better
trademarked it as adrenaline in the US
and so scientists in the US um saidwell
let's not use the trademark name we'll
call it epinephrine and then over in
England they were going to do the same
thing and then somebody made the
argument well epinephrine is the thing
that we know doesn't work so let's call
it the other name and so now we have two
names for the same
Mormon oh that's not confusing at all
very good very good stuff and I mean I
do this is this is one of my just like
very like particular hobby horses I
really wish that for like medical and
scientific applications we could just
decide whether we wanted to do Greek or
Latin Roots um cuz yeah like renal for
kidneys and also like nefro or nefron
for kidneys like it's yeah you go to the
nephologist to get your renal whatever
checked yeah it's ridiculous just just
choose one or the other yeah if you're
going to try to stake a claim on that
there's also all of the uh so-called
Latin names for species of things which
are all mixed up sometimes in the same
word they'll take like a a Greek root
word and a Latin ending or vice versa
it's a mess good luck it it really is I
mean like we already use kind of a
Germanic and romance Blended language as
kind of our base speech so for for
scientific and medical applications just
just choose either Greek or Latin we
don't need to blend those two as well we
love to blend stuff together well good
luck with getting everybody on board
with that I I have no plans to who cares
whatever okay so as for this hormone
okay so people have probably heard of
adrenaline or epinephrine um and that is
made in the inner part of your adrenal
gland so it's called the Adrenal medulla
um and it makes epinephrine
norepinephrine it's mostly regulated by
your nervous system um and then around
the Adrenal medulla you have this cortex
okay so this entire thing is sitting on
top of your kidney like a hat so you
have two of them um and in this cortex
there are here's more fun um atmology so
it's in the cortex meaning like the
shell of the adrenal gland and so these
are your corticosteroids because they
are steroid hormones made in the cortex
MH of the adrenal gland um and so there
are three layers of the cortex and the
middle layer is the one that makes
cortisol so the other two just to
mention them briefly there is um the
innermost layer the Zona reticula makes
DHEA which gets made into um sex
steroids like um testosterone and then
the outermost layer is the zono
glomerulosa and that makes the
mineralocorticoids like aldosterone
which um it's a it's a hormone that
talks to the kidneys and then the kid
have a hormone that talks back to it and
they regulate um electrolytes and water
so this middle section um makes the
glucocorticoids of which cortisol is the
main one and the one we'll be talking
about um and they are socalled because
they are from the cortex and they
regulate blood glucose they can increase
the amount of glucose in your blood
which I I think epinephrine also does um
a little bit
differently um so cortisol is considered
a is is often called a stress hormone
which is true that's not wrong but it's
also only part of the picture so
sometimes especially in these Tik toks
people will talk about being in fight
ORF flight mode and when we think of the
fight ORF flight response we're usually
thinking of epinephrine um which is
something that like our body can sort of
release and use very quickly but if we
have a longer period of stress um
cortisol is usually involved in managing
that stress response for a longer period
of time you know like hours to days to
weeks and that includes thing not just
like stress like oh I had a hard day at
work I'm stressed but like if your body
is undergoing you know an illness or you
had surgery right or you know something
like that um in pregnancy your cortisol
levels go up to like two to four times
normal because it's like a stressful
time for your body your body has a lot
of to get done and so this is part
of that and this is essential for life
you can actually die if you do not have
enough cortisol to manage these
stressful situations absolutely and it
uh it it also helps with sort of like
sensory regulation of stressful things
as well like one of one of the things
implicated in the acute cortisol
response is it decreases sensations of
like pain and discomfort um and there
are also like some perceptual changes
that occur if if someone were to use
like drugs that mimic the
glucocorticoids like it it helps with
some of that stuff as well so like both
both the increase in cortisol like it it
helps with glucose regulation but it
also helps with regulations of
Sensations that you might experience
during a stressful situation as well so
it's it's uh it's good for for
energetics and also just kind of like
good for The Vibes like it it broadly
helps you feel better yeah and I've I've
heard a um an endocrinologist describe
it as a euphoric feeling when somebody
goes on um corticosteroid right so like
they take you know like cortisone or
prazone or something which are all in
the same family and he was bringing it
up in the case of somebody who like
doesn't need these drugs but thinks they
do thinks there's something wrong with
their adrenal gland and takes them and
feels better and he's like well
everybody feels better when you take C
steroids yeah so to talk about a couple
of other things that cortisol does um it
does a lot of things and um and so one
thing it does one reason why it's often
used as a medication is it suppresses
inflammation um it also increases your
blood sugar um it tells your liver to do
gluconeogenesis making glucose out of um
certain amino acids and certain fatty
acids um it tells your muscles to stop
taking up glucose from the blood because
it's trying to keep blood glucose high
and then your muscles can then start
breaking down protein to use as fuel so
you can get like in extreme cases you
can get some muscle wasting um and um it
regulates blood pressure and if you
don't have enough it you can have
something called an adrenal crisis which
can lead to shock and seizures and coma
and eventually death so um some
something interesting I learned while
researching this was that um people who
have a deficiency in their adrenal gland
where they can't make enough cortisol
like Addison's disease um if their
symptoms are mild they're usually kind
of fine but then if they have an illness
or surgery or something like that that's
when they can go into this adrenal
crisis because they don't have the
cortisol to manage it
ands if you know you are going to have a
surgery or if you have like a medical
issue um you actually have to increase
your your dose of cortisone um so that
you don't die that that is that is very
interesting that that isn't something
that I had encountered before yeah um I
mean it it it makes sense if if uh you
have an important hormone in your body
that helps regulate the stress response
that you either don't produce or don't
produce enough of I mean I I guess it's
the same thing as like a diabetic
needing to take a higher dose of insulin
uh if they're going to eat a really
carbage meal like it's it's the same
thing like but in this case the carbage
meal is just a really stressful
experience you're going to have to go go
through so yeah I mean it it makes sense
that they would need to take more of it
exogenously but yeah that that isn't
something that that had ever occurred to
me before that's that's really cool um
so cortisol fluctuates during the day
and I know you're going to talk a little
bit about this in a minute um so it is
lowest it's usually lowest at night when
you go to bed and it rises it starts to
rise as it gets close to the morning um
and then it actually keeps on going and
it tends to Peak a little bit after you
wake up um and so if you're ever getting
your cortisol tested or your adrenal
function tested um they have to take
this into account so you can't just take
a cortisol measurement at some random
time of day um there there's also a type
of test that like naturopaths and
chiropractors will order sometimes that
like takes salivary cortisol at a bunch
of different points which gives you a
really cool looking graph that
endocrinologists are like that that's
useless though that that's not what
matters so um so in endocrinology well
so if they do want to take a test like
that they'll usually do it at night when
it's lowest to see what is the level
when it's as low as it gets um but also
if you're going to be testing your
adrenal function and I think in a little
bit we'll get into why people might
think they need to test their adrenal
function um yeah I I just realized
there's something that I didn't talk
about that will be good to talk about
right now which is what controls your
adrenal gland what tells your adrenal
gland to make this hormone so a lot of
hormones a lot of glands in the body
they make a hormone but they also have a
hormone that tells them when to do that
and so um and so one of the things that
an endocrinologist would test if you
said hey I think I have an issue with my
cortisol is would give you this hormone
so it's called act they would give you a
synthetic version of it and then see
whether your cortisol levels rise after
you get this hormone and they should go
up within a few minutes of getting this
hormone and this brings up something
else that's like a buzzword you'll see
in some of these Tik toks the HPA axis
cortisol comes from your adrenal gland
your adrenal gland gets its instructions
through this act hormone
adrenocorticotropic hormone from the
pituitary the pituitary is this little
gland that's kind of in the middle of
your head like right under your brain
and that gets its instructions from the
hypothalamus which is part of your brain
so your brain tells the pituitary we're
going to need some cortisol the
pituitary tells the adrenal gland start
making some cortisol and so that is your
HPA axis your hypothalamus pituitary
adrenal gland axis and the last thing I
wanted to mention about this is because
like I said it is a real there there are
real medical conditions so there are
disorders where you can have too little
cortisol like Addison disease which is
usually caused by like an autoimmune
kind of thing destroying the adrenal
gland or sometimes by just taking so
much endogenous cortisone that your your
body is like whatever I don't need to
make it anymore and then there's this
other one that I think is going to come
up a bit as we talk about these Tik toks
which is Cushing syndrome um there's
Cushing's Disease and Cushing syndrome
Cushing disease being one of the causes
of it and Cushing syndrome is when you
have too much cortisol and one of the
typical causes is a pitu Ary tumor that
is making the pituitary send out this
hormone this act so that it's constantly
telling your adrenal gland to make
cortisol even when you have too much
cortisol in your bloodstream already oh
and then just one last thing there are
some conditions that aren't Cushings or
cancer where you might have
pathologically high cortisol and they
include like very high stress states
that your body might be in including
alcohol use disorder late stage chronic
kidney disease um major depression and
anxi
and some things like that yeah that that
makes
sense so how would someone go about
testing for like one of these actual
cortisol related diseases
versus um yeah ju just kind of like the
nebulous stuff you see on social media
where where people just think like oh I
generally don't feel good so I'm just
going to assume my cortisol is out of
whack yeah so yeah the the things that
according to Social Media tell you your
cortisol is high can include so many
things some of which might it's funny
when they have these lists of symptoms
because some of them are just like
symptoms of Cushing syndrome and then
some of them are just like completely
normal things like you're tired
sometimes but endocrinologists can like
they have tests for it right they can do
like the nighttime salivary cortisol I
know if they think there's an issue with
your adrenal glands not making enough
cortisol they can give you this hormone
the act and then see how your cortisol
changes in response and there can be
other stuff it can be very um difficult
to diagnose some of these things and
figure out exactly what's going on but
um I will say if you think you have an
issue go to an endocrinologist not a
chiropractor or a person who says they
are a hormone health coach makes sense
yeah
yeah well Greg since a lot of the claims
about cortisol are uh claims about the
effects of high cortisol could you talk
a little bit about normal cortisol
levels and the amount of variability
within the range of normal cortisol
levels um and maybe some of the things
that influence those levels yeah yeah so
um I there there there will be a part of
what I'm going to say that might steal
the Thunder of the Tik Tock stuff a
little bit later but we we wanted to
kind of frontload this episode with like
actual solid scientific information so
people are like slightly inoculated
against some of the claims that that
they will encounter later in this
episode um but yeah so so just to talk
about this a little bit more um if
someone were to be concerned that they
have uh like high cortisol and that's
causing all sorts of problems for them
one thing just to note is that the
reference range of cortisol is very wide
um and and for everything I'm about to
talk about here there will be sources
Linked In the show notes um yeah like
the reference range for for free
cortisol which is kind of the Unbound
bioactive form of cortisol in your blood
is like 0.12 to 1.06 5 microgr per
deciliter which is what like a 8 9fold
range um at 8 a.m. which is when it
would often be tested um and the
reference range for total cortisol in
adults is like 5 to 23 microgr per
deciliter in the morning um and like 3
to 13 micrograms per diler uh in the
afternoon so you know you're looking at
reference ranges that cover about a
fourfold range and so you know I if if
someone were to get a test done and
they're like oh like my qutool is
slightly above kind of the midpoint of
of the reference range that wouldn't
necessarily even be that scary just
because Normal cortisol levels do cover
such a wide range right um and just like
another thing to note uh and this is the
part that's like slightly stealing the
Thunder of of what is to come is a lot
of the claims that people make on social
media about cortisol and ideas around
like do you have high low cortisol you
don't want to go to the doctor you don't
want to take a test but like how can you
how can you know just from how you feel
um a lot of it is related to like
feeling groggy in the morning and like
more energetic at night um something
that I think I would more so interpret
as just generally having a like a late
shifted chronotype um but that's
something that people talk about a lot
and I think a lot of those claims and H
just like General misunderstandings
about
um yeah just like how you might feel uh
related to like High versus low cortisol
levels early or late in the day I think
a lot of that stuff could just be
debunked or better understood just by
doing a really quick skim of the
Wikipedia page for the cortisol
Awakening response um because that
that's what a lot of it comes down to
like the idea uh like Beth mentioned is
that there is like dial variation in
cortisol levels it's usually highest
around the time you wake up peaking 30
to 60 minutes after you wake up and then
gradually declining throughout the day
so um like a lot of the claims are that
oh like if you're cortisol is up
like it's way too low in the morning and
then it's high at night and that's why
you're tired in the morning wired at
night whatever um but like there is also
much like the reference range for
cortisol being pretty broad there's
quite a bit of just completely normal
interindividual variation in terms of
the cortisol Awakening response so after
Awakening um in general you see about a
50% increase in blood cortisol levels uh
with within 30 to 60 minutes after uh
after waking but like the normal
variation is like 38 to
75% so not everyone has the same uh
cortisol Awakening response and that
cortisol Awakening response is only
observed in about 3/4 of healthy people
so you know there are folks that don't
have that and I don't think like all of
the reasons for that are totally known
um yeah so it's there's wide varability
and it's not Universal even in healthy
people another thing to note is that
like a lot of the claims about cortisol
are related to like oh like you're doing
these things that's like up your
cortisol blah blah blah whatever um but
one thing to note about it is that it
does seem to be relatively stable within
an individual and uh at least partially
genetically determined or at least
influenced so um like the DI Al cortisol
pattern that you see in an individual
does tend to be relatively stable over
time and twin studies show that its
pattern um does appear to be heritable
so uh this is too big of a topic for
this episode but like there's there's a
difference between like just a standard
correlation and heritability estimates
not worth getting into here but the
heritability of uh like di dial cortisol
response like iral cortisol pattern is
like4 to like 48 so like it does seem to
be not completely but significantly
heritable um suggesting that it is
probably at least to some extent innate
and not just like purely caused or
determined by lifestyle factors um so
yeah like lifestyle factors do probably
influence it but it does seem to be at
least partially innate and likely linked
to
chronotypes just some other things about
the cortisol Awakening response so one
of the things we'll encounter is that a
lot of claims related to cortisol are
like oh you're doing all of these things
that stress you out and like that's
what's up your cortisol response
and leading to a to feeling tired in the
morning wired at night whatever but like
a lot of stressful things do seem to
cause an increase in the cortisol
Awakening response so for instance like
waking up earlier in the morning than
you're typically used to
um causes an increase in the cortisol
Awakening response uh like yeah uh
there's been studies on nurses um
suggesting that like the time that they
have to go in for shifts can affect the
cortisol Awakening response especially
really early shifts but that seems to
mostly be linked to just like less or
Worse quality sleep the night before but
once again it's not like they're doing
something stressful and that's causing a
muted uh Awakening cortisol response
again like tired in the morning wired at
night you see an increase in The
Awakening cortisol response um but then
like other random stuff that you
wouldn't necessarily kind of clock as a
major stressor um Can decrease it so for
instance uh lowf frequency traffic like
noise throughout the night can decrease
the Awakening cortisol response so like
essentially it's it's relatively complex
and the basic Narrative of hey your
stressed that's going to up your
cortisol lead to the smaller cortisol
Awakening response that is not
universally true and also like another
thing to note about it is like a lot of
cortisol related
Claims can be relatively distinct so
things related to dial pattern of
cortisol release and like total cortisol
levels those things aren't necessarily
Associated um like I'll link this in the
show notes but cortisol Awakening
response isn't associated with total
daily cortisol like area under the curve
so uh even if someone were to have a
cortisol related issue um like you
wouldn't have every cortisol related
issue which is often how this stuff is
presented and also like just the idea
that stress is like a cause of all of
this
is like it's probably related to some
extent but the impact of stress on both
Total cortisol levels and cortisol
Awakening responses varies so like
chronic stress uh is associated with
both an increase and a decreased
cortisol Awakening response so you know
it very well could be that um you know
you're going through a stressful period
for weeks months years whatever and you
wake up like bolt awake like you have a
really like exceptionally robust morning
cortisol response or it could um it
seems like kind of burn you out such
that it becomes muted over time so
there's not just one path that that
could take and then like I mentioned
before like a lot of this stuff just
does seem to be related to chronotypes
and so like people could debate cause
and effect here but as one would expect
people who are kind of like morning
types early birds like early shifted
chronotypes do tend to show a larger
cortisol Awakening response than like
evening types or night owls um and a lot
of the cortisol fear mongering would say
oh like if you're a night owl that means
there's something wrong with you and
your cortisol is up but it
could just be that that's like in innate
difference between individuals um that
is totally benign and people are trying
to problematize something that's
relatively normal essentially the the
point I want to make is that it's
relatively complex and that there's
a there's a wide range in just normal
cortisol levels um cortisol Awakening
response isn't particularly well
associated with just total cortisol
levels like you could have a robust
cortisol Awakening response and low
cortisol uh you could have or like high
total cortisol and by vice versa you
could have a low cortisol Awakening
response and either high or low total
cortisol like those two things aren't
particularly predictive of each other
and so like total amount varies cortisol
Awakening response varies for seemingly
a lot of completely benign reasons and a
lot of the sorts of stressors that might
affect uh cortisol levels um they do so
often in unpredictable ways like certain
stressors seem to decrease either total
cortisol or cortisol Awakening response
some seem to increase it and some seem
to cause like a sort of bimodal response
where you either get like increases in
cortisol or decreases in cortisol um and
so it's it's like a lot like a lot of
things on social media a lot of the
narratives around uh cortisol levels do
seem to be
relatively narrow and prescriptive like
hey if this happens to you like that
means this is going on with your
cortisol and like this thing will help
address it um but often times like those
things inherently aren't particularly
predictable just because cortisol
responses do vary so much some aspect of
cortisol levels isn't even predictive of
other aspects and how your cortisol
responds to different stressors can vary
based on the individual and based on the
type of stressor so um there leaves a
lot of room for that misinformation to
creep in like I feel like that's a
Hallmark of these topics where we see
you know a lot of people making claims
on social on Tik Tok is like there is
such a wide variability in how people
experience it and in like a normal range
and a healthy person yeah and I think
it's interesting that a lot of the
things they're calling out are as like
symptoms of like low or high cortisol or
something messing up with Awakening
response like okay but what about Sleep
Disorders like what about sleep apnea
you know which can make you wake up in
the night and feel tired in the morning
um or they'll talk about like feeling
anxious as being a symptom of high
cortisol and overthinking at night when
you're wired at night and it's like okay
but what about people who have anxiety
right yeah they're going to have that
and maybe that comes with high cortisol
maybe it's a cause of high cortisol you
know like like there's a lot of like
chicken and egg stuff yeah separating
the cause and effect yeah yeah and I do
I do think that is often the case like
it's I think it's much more common that
just like something is going on like
something generally bad or something
that you're like processing or
interpreting as bad is happening in your
life either like your job sucks you're
in a shitty
relationship um you're you're like of
low socioeconomic status and you're
dealing with all of the stress
associated with that uh you have an
injury you have an illness whatever like
those things are I I think are more so
like the cause of yeah something
uh like atypical happening with cortisol
and so then like that that is the
problem and if you do have some bad
thing that's cortisol related you would
probably want to address the root cause
of the problem which is like the illness
or the injury or the life circumstances
that are causing perturbations to your
cortisol rather than saying oh my
cortisol is up that is the
problem and if I address the cortisol
suddenly everything will be better yeah
it's a a lot easier to just blame it on
cortisol than being like how do I get
myself out of this shitty relationship
or how do I like get out from under the
boot of this terrible boss you know yeah
so it's it's very it's very
understandable why people would be
wanting like kind of a simple solution
for something that could be a very
difficult problem yeah and the these
social media posts very often like they
talk about it as if it's like a disease
like know the symptoms of this and know
how to get treated or know how to you
know treat yourself but it's it's like a
lens right it's like they're offering
you a lens with which to look at all of
your problems and then you can say oh
well this explains this and this
explains this and like the more you know
the larger and more nebulous it is the
more you can use it as that lens and
then that leads you to like search on
more terms about high cortisol and
whatever and just sort of get trapped in
this versus saying okay I'm waking up at
night and I'm tired in the morning what
are the reasons that might be and what
kind of like Medical Professional should
I ask if I'm having trouble dealing with
this on my own
so we've already started to kind of
tease this a little bit but now that we
know what cortisol actually does and its
real effects um it doesn't seem to quite
compute with with what we're seeing
online and what people are saying about
it Beth what have you been seeing on Tik
Tok about cortisol what are people
saying about it let's get into that yeah
yeah we we've kind of alluded to and
Gest gestured at the types of claims
being made so like what what are people
actually saying let's let's dive in okay
so I I have a list that I've compiled I
think everything here I saw in more than
one Tik Tok um and they they really
range from things that are extremely
vague that everybody probably has
sometimes like being tired or being
anxious to like specific symptoms where
they're like copying it out of a
textbook for like Cushing's Disease or
something like that um and then the
suggested treatments also run arrange
and some of them are like eat more
protein get more sleep that probably
everybody should do yeah and then um but
then some of them are like more specific
things like get you know like buy these
specific supplements so um okay some of
the symptoms of high ctis all according
to Tik Tok cravings for salt and sugar
waking up in the night specifically
between 2 and 4:
a.m. uh being tired in the morning wired
at night uh overthinking or feeling
anxious especially at night having fat
in your belly or love handles or you're
trying to lose weight and not being very
successful about it
um having a round face um being
irritable and maybe I'll talk about this
more later but there there are a bunch
of uh Tik toks where where women are
saying hey if your husband has a short
fuse and he's angry at you all the time
high cortisol oh my God amazing amazing
so then you have to sneak the
supplements into his
drinks um they'll say God what a what a
what a relationship built on trust if if
Lindsay came home and she was just like
or or if if I C her uh just like
drugging you yeah yeah ju just putting
putting a mystery powder in my morning
coffee first I'd be like what the
happening here and two I'd be like
what's going on and she'd be like oh I I
think you have a medical problem that I
diagnosed for you from watching Tik toks
and this is the treatment that some
Jabron said would make you stop
being mean to me all the time I'd be
like damn like our this the there's a
lot of issues there deep clearly our
relationship died years ago and this is
how I'm finding out about it like
there's there's just like so many layers
of just deception and lack of trust
there it's it's incredible wouldn't you
be glad though that it's just you know
an ashwaganda supplement or something
and not poison uh I would yeah just
saying right side and wouldn't you be
glad that I wasn't asking you to change
your behavior instead I was just you
know giving a supplement and saying
that's going to fix everything yeah I'd
be like thanks you've you you have taken
it upon yourself to find an out for my
bad behavior like I'm I'm clearly doing
well here so sad that's rough I I think
that is one of the options though
because one of these Tik Tok showing
showed like the husband like mixing his
own supplements so maybe you could
convince him I don't know but but then
he's going to be so irritable he'll have
that short fuse and you know yell at you
so I don't know all the way down that
one that one's brutal like that's there
there's layers to that one yeah what
else yeah yeah some more symptoms um
brain fog or troublemaking decisions um
um puffiness or bloating or fluid in
your face or in your body really
anywhere um painful periods or pretty
much any kind of menstrual issue low
libido gut issues of any kind one of the
Tik toks specifically said of any kind
bloating gas anything anything relating
to your gut or that you think relates to
your gut that is high cortisol um broad
net low appetite in the morning so if
you skip breakfast that's you um if you
have high blood sugar which you can tell
because you're shaky often and acne and
just a quick note about the high blood
sugar I'm not sure how they're expecting
people to like know personally whether
they are experiencing high blood sugar
like I remember taking a a first aid
class and they talk about like what to
do if somebody has low blood sugar and
they're like symptoms of low blood sugar
are this symptoms of high blood sugar
are almost exactly the same thing yeah
just assume that in a first aid context
assume they have low blood sugar because
you're not going to kill anybody by
giving them too much you know sugar but
um but it's like how are you supposed to
diagnose this In Yourself by watching a
Tik Tok gosh you know they'll just like
throw it up in a list of symptoms like
high blood sugar you feel shaky and then
move on you know yeah get a glucose
monitor I guess yeah I was ask they're
probably are people doing that I I think
so yeah that's that's a whole another
thing oh man I I mean so it sounds like
myself and probably everyone listening
to this podcast has high cortisol uh
according to Tik Tok like like yeah I
definitely have these symptoms I have so
many of these yeah I mean I think
everyone has at least one of these
symptoms some of the time yeah yeah and
and some of these you know I recognize
as symptoms of like you know Cushing
syndrome or things like that where like
there is an extreme version of this that
is seen as like a med like a symptom
medically you know like the moon face
thing they'll talk about having like a
round face and in somebody who you know
has a lot of um cortisol or if they're
taking you know medications that have
lots of cortisol in it and like they
will get like a rounder face but then
you also have people on Tik Tok being
like well my face is round how do I make
my face look skinnier I must have high
cortisol oh man you know and like in
Cushings you can have some extra fluid
and edema but then they this ends up
getting like mixed into different like
lymphatic drainage massage GHA like
stuff that's already trendy MH so a
couple of things so in a minute I'll
tell you about ways that Tik Tok says
you can fix your high cortisol but I was
also curious like what do they say is
causing your high cortisol and it's a
very small list the Tik toks are very
big on telling you how you know you have
a problem because then you have the
problem and you have to keep on watching
Tik toks to find out um they're not as
big on like what causes it and they
definitely don't get into like sources
of stress and uh you know like real
sources of stress like in your life and
stuff they say like well maybe you're
feeling stressed all the time um maybe
you're using caffeine too much they like
to blame caffeine M um and then the
other two things like I I was like
trying to make a nice long list and I
have like two other things on my list
which is high-intensity exercise and um
exercising when you're on your period
which they claim are causing your high
cortisol
what so I think I think you can tell us
a little bit more about that in a minute
but first let me tell you how to fix
High cortisol according to Tik Tok all
right so this is this is I think where
it gets fun because
they they can kind of pick anything they
want and say this is a fix for high
cortisol and after you've seen so many
Tik toks saying these are the symptoms
of high cortisol and then you have some
of them it's like I'm tired sometimes I
crave sugar um okay one of my favorites
is um vagal stimulation such as dunking
your face in ice water every morning I
saw somebody doing a a cortisol lowering
Challenge and they were like trying to
do it every morning and dunk their face
in the ice water and try to keep it keep
their face in Long enough that they
could like hum while their face was in
the ice water that sounds terrible it's
like a cold shower but just for your
face yeah I I mean the the thing is like
I think there probably is a kernel of
Truth to that um like I so I'm not sure
about the cortisol piece
specifically um but there there is a
reflex where if you submerge a human's
face in water um you do see like a an
immediate and generally pretty large
decrease in blood pressure m um like
submerging your face in water does seem
to influence autonomic nervous system
function which yeah definitely does
something yeah which which like I can I
I haven't looked into research on this
but like I could buy that that acutely
decreases cortisol levels but it's a
it's a reflex like as soon as your face
is out of the water just everything goes
back to normal so I I don't see how it
would give like lasting the the sorts of
lasting changes people would be
interested in and also if if people are
doing that first thing in the morning
like the tired in the morning wired at
night thing if that's related to the
cortisol Awakening response like that's
when you want cortisol higher not lower
like if if that's the lens you're
looking at it through but I could also
just
see just making your face really
cold uh first thing in the morning like
people do cold plunges for the same
reason seen that and that's making your
whole body cold like I I can see how
that could put some pep in your step
generally but it's not cuz you your body
thinks you're dying it's not because
it's acutely doing to cortisol what you
would want cortisol to do if like low
morning cortisol was making you tired in
the morning yeah yeah and I I think this
may actually have sort of creeped over
from a different corner of Tik Tok where
they talk about um doing things with ice
water for anxiety um you know people
putting like an ice pack on their chest
or something like that and um I didn't
write about this but somebody else at
Life Hacker wrote about this and I
remember editing this piece and she took
talked to some uh like therapists and
stuff asking like is this a real
treatment for anxiety and they said well
if you're having a panic attack it can
be good to sort of ground yourself and
like pay attention to like Sensations
that your body is feeling and so that
would be like a really like distracting
thing you can do and so the sources she
talked to seemed to like it for that
reason but they didn't seem to think it
was doing something like magical to your
nervous system right yeah yeah that
makes sense so some other ways to fix
High cortisol um one of them is eating
protein um okay that's good I guess a
lot of them are taking supplements and
if you look up which supplements
literally every supplement in the world
is on somebody's list of supplements for
high cortisol so maybe we can get a
little more into that later um they'll
talk about getting some sunlight in the
morning or go going for a walk in the
morning they'll talk about not having
not using your phone or not exposing
yourself to Blue Light in the evening um
and and usually a lot of like just
general sleep hygiene tips like sure
that's good um right mhm they'll talk
about doing gentle exercise instead of
high-intensity exercise or instead of
hit specifically they'll tell people to
do more walks maybe do some Pilates or
some gentle
yoga um one uh interesting one is
somatic therapy and there are a couple
of different kinds of this and there's
one where you tap on your forehead and
uh this is supposed to something
something release trauma um there is
some exercises where you roll around on
the floor and like vibrate your body or
like move in certain ways cuz this is is
supposed to like release Trauma from
your body and the trauma is what's
holding the cortisol Etc wow okay uh
relaxation techniques just in general
all kinds of relaxation techniques um
they tell you to eat breakfast they tell
you don't have any coffee until after
breakfast um they tell you to do
lymphatic drainage massage or gacha
which is like use a scraping tool to
kind of like massage your face or your
body um to take fish oil and because
this has to be on every list for
everything eat dark chocolate h yeah I
mean so so if I have this symptom of
craving sugar then I can just eat dark
chocolate good to go yeah oh there's I
mean wait wait there's one that didn't
make the list um if you're craving salt
and sugar except they they like
separated it by a few steps you're
craving salt and sugar then something
something because of this blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah you take a um a shot
glass fill it with orange juice and then
put a bunch of salt in it and then throw
that back like a shot fun yeah I mean
you know if you're craving salt and
sugar I think that might work I I wonder
if uh I wonder if that one in particular
is like Downstream of rapat stuff cuz
like who's that oh man we we can't we
can't do a r diversion I've never heard
of this oh my God Beth this is a this is
a firm recommendation when we get done
recording just Google Ray Pete right
like like the name Ray and then the name
Pete yeah yeah r a y p a t um he was
just this kind of like Underground
dissident nutrition and health guy um
I'm not sure if he's still alive I think
he might be he's certainly not as active
or influential as he used to be but
basically he just had this little blog
and like this little Forum um and he
he's the type of guy that like most
people haven't heard about but folks who
love Ray Pete love Ray Pete like
it's it's sort of like a cult situation
yeah it's like a cult mentality
um yeah he he's relatively big on saying
that like oh like if you want to feel
better eat more sugar like that's good
for you and in particular he's big on
orange juice uh his other big one is or
or like thing that kind of broke
containment of the rapat sphere is the
idea that like calcium in most sources
is a bio available so if you actually
want to like get calcium to your bones
you should dry up and grind up eggshells
and that's like the best source of
calcium uh to be clear like I don't I
don't think his stuff is good but like
just amused by it it's it's Unique and
entertaining and and just hearing like
salt and orange juice I'm like I think I
think that at least comes from the the
rape lineage to some I have to look him
up there it's fun like that it is a fun
Rabbit Hole to go
down so we' talked about some of these
like specific examples uh let's talk
about the larger trends we're seeing in
the discourse here um before diving into
like details of some of these claims
yeah so one of the most fascinating
things that um I learned about this so I
actually reached out to an
endocrinologist um who you know is like
an expert in some of this stuff and
asked him you know about like you know
can you give me some comments on like
this current Trend and he sent me a
podcast that he did I don't remember I
want to say like 2018 or something for
the endocrine society and they talk
about adrenal fatigue and I was like oh
I remember that like I it completely
slipped my mind adrenal fatigue was such
a big deal there were articles on goop
about it everybody was talking about how
their adrenals were fatigued because the
idea is you like you're you're so
stressed and it's so go go go and you
you're just you know like making your
adrenal gland make so much adrenaline or
epinephrine that eventually it just like
tires out and can't do it anymore and
then there are all these symptoms like
being tired in the morning or um you
know like having trouble falling asleep
or salt and sugar Cravings or needing
caffeine to get through the day and it's
like wait a minute and so the funny
thing is in this podcast he talks about
this he talks about like why it's a myth
and what he does with patients who come
to him with these concerns and whatever
and toward the end he said something
like you know these symptoms actually
sound more like symptoms of high
cortisol like they they would have a
better grift if they said these are this
is because your cortisol is high and so
wrote back to him and I'm like oh no
that is actually what they're saying now
and he's like oh maybe somebody listened
to my podcast they've gotten smarter I
what level of irony was there in that
statement like did did he actually think
that ticktockers listen to a indocin
society podcast I I I suspect that was a
joke but okay okay that's that's good
that's good but but it is like they kind
of figured out that like this makes more
sense you know and if it like matches
reality a little bit better then it can
like hook into more things and then you
can say oh well obviously there's this
and obviously you know like you can it
becomes more powerful when you can like
link it to more things is my my theory
here definitely but I find it so
hilarious that the same symptoms that
were supposedly adrenal fatigue are now
symptoms of your adrenal gland working
too hard and so I went and looked back
into adrenal fatigue a little bit
including uh I remembered reading about
it on goop and so I looked it up and
they they first published an article
about it in 2017 by um this Doctor Who
is probably best known for selling a
very expensive juice cleanse and he said
uh by being constantly stressed and
using stimulants to whip our adrenals
that's how he referred to using caffeine
drinking coffee we can drive the whole
Energy System to collapse all kinds of
diseases can be triggered or worsened in
a body environment where the adrenals
are exhausted the way to revitalize your
adrenals may be as simple as getting
regular good night sleep or a little
more complicated this is when the use of
adaptogens comes in handy and then he
tells you to get ashwagandha and other
adaptogens and um yeah and and so both
then and now this very often leads into
a sales pitch for supplements right and
these days especially ashwagandha
although this end endocrinologist um his
name's James fining he he noted that a
lot of the supplements at the time that
were being sold as adrenal support um
were might include or be laced with
cortisone or forms of cortisone so they
would actually have some in them so and
that that's when he was saying like
people feel good when they take that um
I wasn't able to confirm like
specifically what kinds of supplements
might have this in it or not but um yeah
like it's always worth being a little
bit suspicious of supplements in general
because it is not unusual to find them
contaminated like deliberately
contaminated with like actual
Pharmaceuticals I mean that that kind of
makes sense I for for whatever reason
that application of like slipping
Pharmaceuticals into something Han it
ever occurred to me but it it has clear
parallels to lifting supplements um like
there have been there have been so many
instances of people taking like
pre-workouts that they thought were fine
uh going into like a powerlifting meat
or weightlifting meat and then getting
popped for band stimulants because there
was a band stimulant that wasn't on the
label um there's been research on this
like like rates of supplement
contaminations and I mean a lot of
pre-workouts like a lot of things that
people take to put some pep in their
step yeah like they have some caffeine
in it but it also has some like ephedrin
or or just like other other band
stimulants in it um so I mean I guess I
guess it's intuitive that people would
do the same thing for kind of like
Health like Feelgood adaptogen type
supplements a quick fun fact I know that
one of the the categories that has a lot
of this is like sketchy boner pills like
truck stop fake Viagra a lot of the time
there's real VI real Viagra in it
I mean that that makes all the sense in
the world I I think I think it may have
partially been a bit of like an
inferiority complex I guess where like I
look around the fitness industry and I'm
like ah God like this industry is so
stupid like this this would be
the one where people would would lace
their supplements with stuff and think
they could get away with it and whatever
like I I assume that supplements aren't
as sketchy elsewhere but no of course
there sketchy elsewhere I don't I don't
know why I ever assumed that for a
second so like I said I went to Tik Tok
and looked for examples of adrenal
fatigue I found one where a guy was like
here's how you know how you have
symptoms of adrenal fatigue AKA High
cortisol just like straight up saying
they're the same thing those are it's
opposite it's the opposite but you know
what it's the same list of symptoms so
it kind of works right yeah um I found
another really fun one um saying hey if
you had low back pain um and then she
explains that it's because of adrenal
fatigue and so your adrenal glands are
having a problem and your adrenal glands
are on your kidneys and your kidneys are
sort of near your back and so that's why
you have low back pain that is quite the
claim yeah that's that's a stretch
that's creative I'll give her that was
very creative I was I I saw that and I
was I was just like slow clap for that
one I it never would have occurred to me
to put them together that way yeah while
you're talking just really quick I'm
going to see if the adrenal cortex is
even innervated in the first place um
okay they they are are yeah they do get
the splank niic nerves because parts of
the adrenal gland talk to each other but
uh yeah but anyway oh but in terms of
can it feel pain I don't know yeah yeah
that that that's what I was looking at
to see if it had like a sensory nerve
Supply okay so maybe um although I don't
know whether an adrenal gland being
fatigued would necessarily be a painful
condition oh no no like I it wouldn't
establish that I just want to see if
like that's even something that's even
theoretically possible or if it's just
like within the realm of uh is something
that's not even like physiologically on
the
table um and then something else that I
noticed when I was looking up the
adrenal fatigue stuff as I started um
you know there's still a lot of like
chiropractors naturopaths people like
that who will talk about it and like
real endocrinologists will absolutely
say no that's not a thing like there are
diseases that can affect your you know
like health conditions that can involve
your adrenal glands there are lots of
them come on in we'll test you we'll
figure it out but like adrenal fatigue
they're like no that's that's not a
thing if you think adrenal faue maybe
you have something else but it's not but
um but something I saw that at first I
thought was funny and then by the end I
was just like this is horrible um is a
chiropractor who's saying hey look at
this person's lab test it's the worst
I've ever seen and talks about this
person who like is is having trouble
with her relationships and whatever they
did one of these um tests of the
cortisol curve throughout the day and he
holds up the um
like papers like look this is low this
is low and then at the end he said well
she's going to need a lot of work to be
able to fix all of this and I'm going to
do some viral Tex testing next and I
can't wait to see what that turns up so
yeah there's a whole thing where there
are these practitioners that will just
sort of like look for stuff and tell you
you have some kind of health condition
that you need to like keep coming back
to them for and get treated for and you
know I'm more familiar with this with
certain other things but just the idea
that this person is like excited to go
through and tell this person that they
have a virus that they probably don't
have and then have them come back every
week for hundreds of dollars a week for
who knows how long like it's just so now
this becomes like the the adrenal stuff
becomes like an entry point for getting
people into like a whole another yeah
you know thing it's depressing yeah yeah
I I I always wonder with stuff like that
um like to to what extent do those
practitioners actually believe it versus
to what extent do
they realize it's or like I was going to
say to what extent do they realize it's
a grift but I think like a grift implies
some degree of intentionality but yeah
like I I I sometimes wonder CU like I
try to give people the benefit of the
doubt and I'm like ah like people are
making crazy claims but ultimately
they're just uninformed like they're
trying to help and like make a quick
buck off of it like I I get it whatever
like it it is what it is but then
sometimes when when stuff like that gets
so egregious like it becomes so hard to
extend that benefit of the doubt because
it it does get like it can get very dark
I think yeah yeah and like I I have to
assume that it's you know when when you
make when you're getting enough into
this and and hearing from other people
saying the same things to kind of
convince yourself it's all true or close
to to true or something and like all all
of this information is always sort of
like a blend of Truth and fiction it's
never like straight up well right not
usually like completely false stuff you
know but like yeah I'm kind of in the
same place as you like I want to give
people the benefit of the doubt and
assume they're at least trying to do the
right thing but sometimes it's really
hard yeah like really hard to believe
that I mean like you you even see that
as well with um like a lot of the the
symptoms that that people throw out as a
potential indic that you have high
cortisol like uh as you mentioned a lot
of them are just symptoms of Cushing's
Disease and the the thing that like a
lay like this is something that I think
is more like understandable for people
to get wrong and like not as grifty like
if if you're just like a normal person
on Tik Tok and you have no like
scientific or medical training I think
it's easy to look at stuff like that and
not understand
like the importance of the
discriminatory power of a test like for
instance like being being puffy or
having a round face like that very well
could be an indication of Cushing's
Disease but it could be an indication of
of so many other things and in terms of
having a round face like that could just
be your bone structure like that's just
how your face is shaped you know um and
so in an instance like that if someone's
not particularly savvy
like it all seems to make sense they
look up like oh symptoms of high
cortisol here's this disease like it's
characterized by high cortisol here are
some things you see oh like if you
like people with Cushings Disease have
uh like fluid retention round face
puffiness whatever like and then and
then it's a logical fallacy to jump and
say therefore if you have a round face
fluid retention puffiness you have high
cortisol but like that is um like that
that's kind of like a logic trap that I
think people very frequently fall into
and I think that might be what's
happening with with a lot of this here
like they're uh accurately identifying
actual symptoms of high cortisol but
then dramatically overestimating the
discriminatory power of being able to
say if you have these symptoms that
therefore means you have high cortisol
cuz like any number of other things
could be causing them or it could just
be something that's like relatively
normal like like variations in
chronotypes yeah and it it reminds me a
lot of um how sometimes there's like
panic over like certain ingredients in
foods and like oh there's this toxin in
this thing or whatever and it's like
well but how much and like what does
that actually cause and so people don't
necessarily understand like the dose or
whatever they they just see like oh I
see this thing on a list there for
that's going to be significant yeah
right um it's sort of like the the
health version of that and it it's
interesting so there was a an article in
the Washington Post recently of um a
woman who had some of these symptoms and
she was under a lot of stress she was
planning a wedding and she was gaining
weight in like a the pattern that is
supposed to be a high cortisol pattern
and she I I don't think she went to
doctors and said I have high cortisol
but she was like what's going on with my
body um and she did get like a rounder
face you know she went to a lot of
different doctors by the time she
finally like got to the endocrinologist
who was able to diagnose her he was like
bring in pictures of yourself from a
couple of years ago and like there was a
dramatic difference from like having
like a fairly thin face to having a very
round face and she also had an identical
twin so when she's standing next to her
identical twin you can really see the
difference and she turned out to have
cancer that was the cancer was secreting
act which is this hormone that tells the
adrenal gland to make cortisol and um
she ended up getting the tumor removed
and was fine but imagine if she had been
looking at Tik Tok and being like wow I
have to do more yoga and I have to you
know take ashwaganda you know like some
sometimes they're real symptoms real
issues yeah you can't you can't get out
of that one just by putting your face in
ice water yeah or tapping on your
forehead in a particular way yeah so I
did want to talk about um one aspect of
this which is like a lot of this is
targeted at women and it's like these
videos are very often by women for women
and yeah I was like looking at some of
these videos and my my son came in and I
told him what I was doing and he just
kind of looked over my shoulder for a
while and he was like why are they all
women and I was like well let's see what
happens when we search cortisol in men
and that's where I found the ones about
spotting High cortisol in your husband
so so still content by women for women
just about their women for women about
the men in their lives about their
husbands there were a few things where
men are telling women hey if you want to
lose that belly fat here's what you got
to do and then you know telling them
about their High cortisol problems um
love that and the the other thing though
is like this this has come up in almost
every like Tik Tok myth I've looked into
Tik Tok Health misinformation is like
it's all so Beauty and weight loss
focused because if you can if you are a
hot young woman and you can put your
face on Tik Tok you can say anything and
so like the subtext of all of these is
like look how pretty I am your ugly
here's how to be like me and um you know
like if somebody's going to do a
smoothie recipe on Tik Tok they're going
to like be in a crop top so you can see
their abs while they're making their
smoothie like it's extremely common and
and I found it really interesting that
like the number one symptom that came up
in all of these things nearly all of
them mentioned it was you can't lose
weight or you have belly fat or you have
love handles and like it's almost like
there's this assumption that like if you
are not like extremely thin and hot that
you must be trying your very hardest to
become extremely thin and hot um MH you
know it's not even or that if you're not
already thin and hot there's something
medically wrong yeah it's like she's
obviously solved it because she looks
like that so there must be something
wrong with me and she knows the answer
because she doesn't look like me yeah
exactly and and I I like how they would
often phrase it not as weight gain but
as can't lose weight because everybody
should be all like if you're not already
that like 20s something hot girl on Tik
Tok then clearly you are trying to
become her you are trying to lose
and then that kind of puts these sugar
Cravings into perspective I think like
if you're talking to people who are
constantly dieting and there's a lot of
like advice that like makes a lot more
sense in the context of people who are
like constantly dieting or trying to
diet or like thinking about that yeah um
like well yeah you have cravings for
junk food like right you know yeah
you're tired you're eating 800 calories
a day yes yeah and then when they talk
about like high-intensity exercise and
whatever it's like
on the one hand they're probably
overblowing this and exercise doesn't
you know do all the horrible things that
they're saying it does but also like
imagine this picture of somebody who's
constantly trying to lose weight and
like unhappy with their body and
constantly craving junk food and is you
know like sort of in a feedback loop
with this saying I have to work out
harder I have to go and do more hit
videos or go and do more exercise or
whatever and like that that exercise
could be like maladaptive for them in
that scenario not because exercise is
bad but because like this is the the
sort of feedback cycle that is being
encouraged by these Tik toks and also
pathologized by these Tik toks yeah
there are so many things on this list of
symptoms that could just be General
fatigue slash like trying to lose weight
and exercise too hard and like crash
dieting and whatnot like cravings for
salt and sugar yeah like if you're not
eating anything you're going to Crave
things that taste good um waking up at
night like if if the state of low energy
availability can cause sleep
disturbances like that's very well well
known and well established tired in the
morning like no like if you're uh
like extremely under fueled you're not
going to have that much pep in your step
when you get out of bed um then the like
fat belly love handles can't lose weight
like that's you know that's more of kind
of like where you're at now like you're
you you interpret that you must have a
problem because like you're already in
that state and therefore you're doing
all of these things that fatigue you um
irritability like yeah you're tired and
hangry like that makes sense um low
libido again like low energy
availability kills your sex drive uh gut
issues like bloating gas like if you're
not eating anything and then you may be
like go off the rails like your tummy's
going to hurt or if you're just taking a
bunch of weird supplements and you have
a weird diet to try to like crash diet
and lose weight I can see how that would
cause gut issues uh low appetite in the
morning like maybe because you're you
habitually don't eat in the morning
because you're trying to lose weight
like that makes sense and then high
blood sugar SL shaky often like you said
the symptoms of high and low blood sugar
often go hand in hand um so yeah like
maybe you're shaky often because you
have low blood like a lot of those
proposed symptoms of high
cortisol do seem to track pretty well
with like under fueling and over
exercise for the purpose of like trying
to rapidly lose weight mhm yeah and I
think that probably has a lot to do with
why this is becoming a trend because
like people who are sort of like in this
you know trying to be hotter and looking
at Tik toks of hot people trying to
figure out how to get hot like them you
know like puts you in this scenario
where oh hey all of these symptoms match
up for me
MH something else that um also comes up
a lot is you know being focused at on
women and also relevant to the under
fueling thing is they talk about your
menstrual cycle a lot um and I'm sure
this is a whole another subject um but
like people will tell you not to do
intense exercise during certain parts of
your menstrual cycle they'll talk about
like the Cravings that you're having in
certain parts of your cycle you know and
you know as as I'm sure you guys know
like you don't need to change your
exercise or your nutrition all that much
for your your cycle like that doesn't
necessarily follow but also like there
are some like subtle changes in your
cycle about like you might crave more
sugar in certain points or whatever and
like if you actually feed yourself those
things that your body needs you'll get
along a lot better so that ties right
back into the dieting thing and the
under fueling I think um so anyhow I
think that's very interesting because
like if you if you look up like high
cortisol and then like menstrual cycle
put that in your search terms you find
you'll find a lot of people saying you
know like doing high-intensity exercise
the weak of your period is what's
causing your high cortisol all the time
and just kind of making that up yeah
yeah I mean like like you mentioned and
and not to stay on this subject too much
but like that is I I think that that
does dovetail with another really common
thing that that even I have seen on
social media as as someone who doesn't
consume that much of it there is just
there there is so much content about
minstral cycles and so many claims about
what supplements you should take how you
should exercise how you should eat
whether or not you should diet like at
at certain phases of the menstrual cycle
and there there's a degree to which I
understand the the limits of how much my
opinion matters because like it I don't
have any relevant lived experience but
it's also like I do follow the research
on that pretty well and there's a lot of
it and uh like a a a person whose work
like listeners should look into if if
they're interested interested in a lot
of this stuff is uh Lauren kinzo simple
um she she published a really good
narrative review about exercis in in the
menstrual cycle H what was that maybe
like six months ago or so um that is
worth looking into basically making the
case that as far as we can tell acute
physiological responses to exercise
don't seem to vary that much throughout
the menstrual cycle like adaptations to
exercise don't really seem to vary much
if any um and like yeah like that that
is the state of the research like a lot
of which or most of which has been
conducted by women but then there's like
such a large disconnect and if you do
say hey like you know I'm sure that how
you feel uh can vary considerably
throughout the month but maybe that
doesn't necessarily have that large of
an impact on the type of exercise you
can do and benefit from um you know it's
it's easy to get shouted down for you
know not yeah like like staying in your
lane like oh like all all of these other
people say it's important like why don't
you just listen to them it's like if
they're if they're right the research
doesn't support them but yeah like I I
don't know I I do think that a lot of
stuff related to the menstrual cycle is
just like a huge can of worms where
there's a considerable Divergence
between the claims that influencers make
online and what the research actually
says on the topic yeah definitely I have
more thoughts on that maybe that's
another episode or something that would
be fun that would be
fun I do want to move on to something
else that I see a lot in these Tik toks
about women talking about cortisol and
whatever and there's this thing came up
so much about the idea that trauma is
what's causing both your high cortisol
and your inability to lose weight and so
they don't go much body keeps the score
the body keeps the score I have hell
yeah I know so many people love that
book I have not read it I'm neither
criticizing nor uh the opposite of that
that book but but there's so many of
these that were talking about how like
your body's not getting rid of the fat
because your body wants to protect you
because you have trauma in your past and
so instead of just going to therapy and
talking it out you have to like get your
body to get the trauma out of your body
and then this is where all of these
different like physical therapies come
in and there are ones where you're
supposed to like lay on the floor and
like wiggle your hips a little bit and
then just like do that for 10 minutes
and then do it some more and there are
like videos like time-lapse videos of
people doing some of these things where
it's like they're sort of like vibrating
and rolling around or whatever and um
yeah and then the the EFT tapping is
like a sort of like an acupressure kind
of thing you're supposed to like tap on
certain parts of your body on like your
forehead and I'm not sure where else
while you're like saying certain I don't
know affirmations or things about
yourself and this is supposed to like if
you're going to take this in like a more
medical Direction you can say well these
things are relaxing and relaxation is
good for stress and so on and then some
people will take it in more of like the
pseudoscientific direction being like we
have to convince your body to let go of
the trauma because the trauma is what's
holding the fat etc etc um interesting
curious if you have thoughts on that
yeah I mean I I think physiologically
it's wrong but unlike unlike the the
doctor who was trying to like or not
doctor chiropra or whatever who is
trying to find like viral and just
like really really put someone down a
bad and relatively costly path SL
lucrative for him path like this is
stuff that I think is
ultimately yeah like like
physiologically unfounded but relatively
benign yeah like it it's not going to
hurt anyone and it's one of those things
where I I could see how it could
generate some expectancy effects like if
if your self-concept is I am someone who
has struggled losing weight and then
someone proposes that like and like
losing weight is something that matters
deeply to you and someone proposes that
like this is the reason why you've been
unable to do things and like if you uh
like tap on your head or like roll
around on the ground in a certain way
like that will be the thing that like
allows you to break through um I could
see how that could be beneficial for
some people even if it's not actually
doing what the proponents claim that it
is um like yeah if if you do have that
mental block of like I'm someone who
wants to lose weight but is unable to
just like a a relatively benign thing if
it can help you like flip that switch in
your head of hey I've learned I I've
learned this thing that that has been
holding me back and I've learned what to
do to get past it so like now that
blocker is gone and now uh even though
it's like somewhat coming from an
external Source I can now feel some
degree of self-efficacy about my ability
to purs this thing like I don't know I I
could see it being helpful and uh even
though I think it's probably wrong um
and so yeah like that's that's not the
type of thing that I think I would be
likely to get that been out of shape
about yeah I think it might kind of
depend on like what happens next yeah
like so you do the the tapping or the
rolling around or whatever and then like
what do you do because sometimes the
people who are are advocating this stuff
are also selling a whole bunch of
supplements or they'll end up sending
you to a you know naturopath or
something and like is this like a
Gateway into stuff that takes you
further away from anything that would
help you or be healthy for you or is
this something that helps you to take a
little more control of your yourself and
and be like okay well I'm doing if I did
that then I can do the next thing and so
I think it really kind of depends where
it takes you yeah you you've released
the trauma now you can deadlift you know
now you can deadlift every week week of
the month
yeah so back on that topic about
exercise right so there's this um this
idea which I've seen both both in this
context and in the context of like
menstrual cycle stuff about the idea
that high-intensity exercise spikes your
cortisol and makes you gain weight which
is why going to the gym and either
lifting weights or doing high-intensity
stuff like you know hit like Sprint
training like sometimes they'll just say
running in general um what counts high
intensity kind of depends on the
influencer um but they'll say exercise
spikes your cortisol makes you have more
cortisol therefore if you want to lose
weight or if you want to deal with the
symptoms of stress you shouldn't do any
of that stuff so what do you think of
that yeah I mean I I have a lot of
thoughts uh I I think that this is
another area where like there is
definitely a kernel of Truth um intense
exercise does cause elevations in
cortisol um but but I also think that H
like I I I think it's a contextual thing
and the idea that anything that
increases cortisol is necessarily bad is
completely wrong so uh to start with
like a lot of the symptoms that people
are describing that they would associate
with um that are being associated with
high cortisol in Tik Tok content um like
a lot of the fatigue like feeling bad
blah blah blah whatever like if that
were to have an origin in exercise it
sounds reminiscent of overtraining
syndrome um and overtraining syndrome is
characterized by low cortisol levels not
high cortisol levels so like there's a
there's kind of a phasic response to it
like when you start training hard act
and cortisol both go up and then like as
you start over and but and that's like
good an Adaptive like that's when things
are still going well like you're
training hard you're still adapting well
to it uh hormonally everything is
working normally and like kind of doing
what it's supposed to then when you
start getting into the realm of
overreaching like you know you're still
able to perform well but like maybe
you're not adapting quite as well
anymore you're starting to get worn down
uh what you start seeing is what appears
to be like a a resistance to uh act so
act levels keep going up um like your
pituitary keeps telling your adrenal
glands hey produce more cortisol like
this person's training hard it's what
they need um but cortisol levels Plateau
or maybe start declining and then with
like true overtraining syndrome you
start seeing act and cortisol both going
down um which which like if anything
would be like a real case of adrenal
fatigue or at least like something
reminiscent of it
but in essence if there is an exercise
related cause of the symptoms that
people are reporting it would in all
likelihood be related to over fatigue
overtraining and a decrease in cortisol
levels rather than an increase now I I
did end up reading about um at least
sometimes there can be a a condition
where people have high cortisol so this
was in a paper from an endocrinologist
where people have high cortisol um not
necessarily like the classic Cushing
symptoms and he said this can happen in
red s so relative energy deficiency so
kind of like overtraining with not
enough calories and you can also see
something like this in anorexia too yeah
yeah yeah so that that that is a good
point like there's there's a lot of
overlap between I mean it's it's a it's
a classic bit of like social media
content F like is it overtraining or
under recovering SL underere eating um
and so yeah like if if you have like
overtraining like symptoms not
necessarily because your training is
that crazy but it's too much relative to
to the amount you're eating and you're
dealing with relative energy deficiency
you're under fueling um yeah you you
could see elevations in cortisol with
that but if if it's like a purely
exercise based ideology like you're you
seem to be doing what you would need to
do to fuel well for training but you're
still just training so much that you're
overtraining um like that that's when
you generally see decreases in cortisol
and either way these are very like
extreme conditions right we're not
talking about somebody who's just like
you know working out three days in a row
instead of taking a rest day which is
when people think they're like it's it's
almost exclusively observed in
professional athletes who you know and I
mean honestly mostly endurance athletes
as well like folks folks who might be
putting in like a 100 miles a week um
and if that's not you like H you might
be a little worn down you're probably
not like truly overtrained um at least
in the scientific sense um so yeah
that's that's the first thing the second
thing is that cortisol does increase
during intense exercise and like uh the
the claim that it increases most during
intense exercise is correct I'll link a
source in the show notes but uh there
was a 2008 paper that looked into kind
of the threshold effect of when cortisol
starts going up um relative to exercise
intensity so they had people do 30
minutes of I think treadmill running it
could have been cycling doesn't matter
whatever it was it was aerobic exercise
at uh 40 60 and 80% of V2 Max and what
they found essentially was that um both
at rest and 40% of V2 Max you you
basically didn't have any changes in
cortisol levels like at rest went down
like 6% % at
40% uh of V2 Max it went up 6% but like
given how wide the range of cortisol is
like that's that's functionally no
change but then when you go from 40% to
60% there was like a 40% increase and
then at 80% of V2 Max it was like an 80%
increase so like once you clear that
kind of like 40 50% of V2 Max threshold
that is when you start seeing a
relatively quick and relatively large
increase and cortisol levels um but that
is not necessarily a bad thing um in
fact it is good and normal and it
relates to the intricate hormonal
regulation of uh energetic substrates
that allow for high performance without
compromising the energy status in
tissues other than muscles essentially
like your your body is trying to balance
a lot of things during exercise like you
need to get enough fuel to your muscles
and your muscles to just have access to
enough fuel for them to be able to
perform well like to be able to contract
with a lot of force to put out force
over a long duration in the case of
cardio like they they are they are
burning through a lot of energy um but
like you still need to stay conscious uh
like you still have other organs that
need to be doing stuff um and so like
you can't have the muscles just sucking
up every energetic substrate uh going
through the bloodstream and so like
cortisol kind of helps provide some
balance to to that intricate regulatory
process so like you mentioned earlier
Beth but but just to bring some of this
back so it's fresh in people's minds
cortisol is involved in blood glucose
regulation so cortisol stimulates
gluconeogenesis in the liver uh and also
glycogenesis in the liver so um like it
helps the liver make more glucose out of
non-glucose substrates and it also helps
the liver synthesize more of its own
glycogen uh while cortisol also
stimulates glycogenolysis and reduces
glucose uptake in the muscles so it
helps the muscles break down the
glycogen they already have stored and
keeps them from sucking up as much
additional glucose from the bloodstream
cortisol also increases lipolysis so
like the breakdown of fat F acids and
the release of fatty acids into the
bloodstream to serve as a fuel source
and also increases protein degradation
so I know that endurance athletes have
fairly high protein requirements um and
I know that that's because your body
uses some muscle tissue for fuel during
like long endurance stuff is that
related to this because cortisol is
going to be encouraging some amount of
muscle breakdown uh it could be it could
be I think that that's related but it's
not the main cause so uh especially if
someone's doing like really really long
duration uh endurance exercise like that
could certainly be a contributor but
like another thing that I think is
relatively slept on is that there is a
very large muscle protein synthetic
response to aerobic training um and we
tend to associate that with muscle
growth and hypertrophy but uh after
exercise you actually have a larger
increase in muscle protein synthesis in
in your type one fibers than type two
and a lot of that is directed towards
kind of like more of the like metabolic
enzymes like a lot of the anerobic
metabolic enzymes um like mitochondrial
protein synthesis and so like when you
split out um like myofibrillar versus
sarcoplasmic protein synthesis you do
tend to see greater myofibrillar protein
synthesis after resistance training but
like total protein
synthesis is generally really still a
little higher after resistance training
than aerobic training but it's it's
actually like relatively comparable just
because like all of those other protein
fractions have have like a very robust
elevation in synthesis uh after aerobic
training so you you are kind of fueling
a a protein synthetic response that is
comparable in magnitude after both forms
of exercise and it's just kind of a
question of where that protein synthesis
is being directed towards like is it
more towards muscle growth or it more
towards like the the like metabolic like
anerobic enzymes and mitochondria and
all of that stuff uh another thing that
I came across when reading about
cortisol more is um to an extent the the
cortisol increases you see with exercise
are actually beneficial to muscle
remodeling um cuz like you need some
degree of protein turnover and
effectively like it it increases the
breakdown of proteins but then based on
the hormonal and just like the the milu
of signaling molecules that are present
in the muscle after exercise that kind
of tells your body hey based on this
stimulus that that I was just exposed to
what sort of adaptation do I need and so
like the muscle protein breakdown you
get during exercise increases the free
amino acid pool that can then be
directed to like Sy sizing new useful
proteins so it could be that like you
currently have a muscular phenotype
that's like not the best adapted to
whatever type of exercise training
you're doing and so it's actually
beneficial to break down some proteins
that you're not using as much so you can
use those amino acids to like synthesize
proteins you do now need more so yeah
like the the muscle protein breakdown
you get from cortisol isn't like you
shouldn't necessarily assume that and
I'm not saying you do this but just like
for the listener you shouldn't
necessarily assume all muscle protein
synthesis is muscle growth there are a
lot of proteins being synthesized that
aren't just like contractile proteins
and you shouldn't necessarily assume
that muscle protein breakdown scales one
to one with muscle loss like it does
also just increase the free amino acid
pool that can be directed to like useful
synthetic like muscle protein synthesis
responses so that is super interesting
uh going back no problem um so yeah
going back to cortisol during exercise
your muscles do need to burn through uh
a ludicrous amount of energy pretty
quickly and especially so during
high-intensity exercise uh but you need
to basically keep all of your other
organ systems fueled and online as well
and so everything cortisol does related
to energy metabolism uh either
facilitates actual performance during
exercise or helps protect those other
organ systems so to start with as as
mentioned
uh it helps with glycogenolysis in the
muscles so it helps the muscles break
down the glucose that is already stored
to make it more accessible to be burned
to fuel exercise it also causes
lipolysis so that helps make fatty acids
more available uh to be used as a fuel
source um and that's especially helpful
for long duration exercise so like if
you were doing low intensity long
duration cardio your cortisol levels
would be low to start with but they
would gradually increase throughout the
session and so they're not ramping up
because you need to make glucose more
available they're ramping up because you
need to make fatty acids more available
and uh protein degradation as mentioned
like that can have beneficial functions
on just like protein remodeling um but
also for exercise performance a lot of
amino acids can enter the KB cycle
directly so it's giving your muscles
access to another like Fast fuel fuel
source um and also as mentioned
previously cortisol inhibits sensations
of pain and discomfort so um it helps
with being able to keep pushing hard
even if your muscles are burning like
something hurts you don't feel good like
the cortisol release during during
high-intensity exercise helps you keep
performing um even though like Hard
Exercise is kind of uncomfortable it it
reduces uh the discomfort you
experience and then uh most of the other
functions of cortisol help protect other
organ systems from an energetic crisis
because your muscles are just like so
thirsty for all of the fuel that they
can possibly use so um cortisol reduces
glucose uptake in the muscles and that's
very important because you only have
like 4 to8 gram of glucose in your blood
at any given point in time and your
liver also Only Stores about 100 G of
glycogen at any given point in time
and that is basically the fuel reserve
for all of your other
organs and so like if your muscles got
too greedy and just like Su all of the
glucose up that came by them like you
would kind of be uh like you want
cortisol to ramp up to kind of slow that
process down um cuz like during exercise
and like just normal physical activity
you undergo a process called non-insulin
mediated glute for translocation which
is essentially the little gluc the
glucose Transporters in your muscles um
they're usually kind of on the inside of
the cirma and not exposed to the
capillaries um but then what insulin
does and also just what exercise does is
it kind of signals to those glute 4
Transporters to translocate uh to the
other side of the membrane such that
glucose in the blood kind of can link up
with them and and come through into the
muscle and so you already get a lot of
glute 4
translocation uh just from muscle
contraction like that is a stimulus for
glute four translocation so uh like an
increase in cortisol to keep that from
like being absolutely maximal so that
your muscles aren't just sucking up all
of the glucose out of your blood um
helps make sure that glucose is
available for other organs and and other
organ systems moving on uh cortisol
causes protein degradation
and uh also increases gluconeogenesis
and glycogenolysis in the liver um and
that basically helps the liver rep
replete its fuel tank in real time
during exercise because again like your
liver doesn't store that much glycogen
and your muscles are burning through so
much fuel that especially during long
duration exercise if your liver is still
going to have glycogen to get to your
brain to get to your heart to get to all
of your other organs um you know if if
you were doing long duration exercise
that that burned through like 400 total
calories without a way to replenish that
fuel tank of the liver um you would be
in trouble like you you'd run out of
fuel you and you'd pass out um so
cortisol helps coordinate that like it
it kind of gives the liver the shove it
needs to take up some of the Protein
that's being broken down to take up some
of the other substrates in the blood
that can be converted into glucose and
convert that stuff into glucose and
store it as liver glycogen more rapidly
than it would otherwise so like those
two things cortisol does they help
protect the rest of the body from the
muscles that are these these greedy
Little Hungry Hungry Hippos that would
otherwise just uh steal all of the fuel
and and you would tap out and so yeah
like acutely it does stuff that you want
it to do to be able to perform well and
not lose Consciousness and then in terms
of if that's going to negatively affect
you uh it won't so if you if you
exercise hard and you get a spike in
cortisol and it goes up uh that's not
scary like it goes back to resting
levels in about 40 to 60 minutes after
exercise um so wait wait wait Tik Tok
told me that I've been doing if I've
been doing high-intensity exercise I
might need to take a month off from the
gym uh so 40 minutes 40 minutes is good
if you're experience if you're
experiencing overtraining syndrome like
that can be a relatively long recovery
process but yeah like just cortisol
going up during exercise if there's
nothing else wrong with you yeah it goes
up and it comes back down within an hour
um it it is not going to keep you in a
state of like high cortisol for days or
weeks or months at a time or even hours
at a time again like it goes up comes
back down within like 40 to 60 minutes
um and so yeah like I think I think a
lot of that dovet tales with like an
erroneous type of idea that I I see
people throw out sometimes that they
don't apply evenly across the board and
that's the idea that like if there is a
hormone that is presented as being scary
the idea is that any elevation in that
hormone is necessarily scary and bad and
deleterious um and that's just not the
case so like a good example here would
be like people being afraid that their
insulin like quote unquote spikes after
eating carbs and they think like oh like
that's bad that's indicative of poor
metabolic health I'm going to give
myself diabetes because my body had to
like release some insulin and that's not
the case like if otherwise you're in
decent metabolic Health your body your
insulin should Spike when when you eat
carbs because you need to get that
glucose out of your bloodstream insulin
helps facilitate that and it's very
similar with cortisol like absolutely if
you have like pathological conditions
related to cortisol like Addison's
disease Cushing's Disease something like
that either too much or too little
cortisol could be a major problem but if
it's just a matter of
you expose your body to a stimulus where
an elevation and cortisol is the
appropriate response you want that to
occur and it's not representative of any
sort of problem it's it's just like a
normal hormonal response to the stressor
you know what this reminds me of a lot
of these these people will say like we
we say you need to take adaptogens right
like these supplements and they'll
they'll explain an adaptogen is
something that helps your body deal with
stress when it needs to but that doesn't
you know that isn't a bad thing for you
overall and it's like kind of sounds
like cortisol is an adaptogen it's doing
that thing yeah yeah like it it uh it
like mediates the hormetic response to
exercise I think that like with with
something like cortisol or insulin like
people do have this idea that any like
Spike or elevation in the hormone is bad
because they think the hormone is bad
and kind of by extension like any
hormonal perturbation is like bad and
scary and you should be afraid of it but
like that's not really applied across
the board so you know you if you look at
it through the lens of this is a normal
thing to experience given the the
stressor or like the stimulus like it
doesn't seem scary but like when you
look at things like melatonin like your
melatonin spikes during the evening but
like no one's afraid of of that or like
growth hormones spikes during the night
and like no one is afraid of that but
the the idea that yeah like if if if
people present a hormone as scary now
suddenly any elevation of it is a scary
thing but when people think that
something's benign they're like oh like
it it's spikes it goes up and down
that's fine like who cares if like
elevations and cortisol were like an
inherently bad thing like Evolution
would have sorted that out by now like
we wouldn't produce cortisol in the
first place uh but yeah it it is just
interesting to me how differently the
lenses people look through this stuff
are based on whether their preconceived
notions are that a particular hormone is
like a good hormone or a bad hormone
when physiology is like dramatically
more complex than that and we're a lot
more adaptable than sometimes they give
us credit for absolutely
yeah we have a really broad overview I
think at this point and have have
realized that cortisol is not scary
which is good um and we've talked a
little bit about just like the list of
claims being made on Tik Tok but I think
the next thing is digging in zooming in
on some of these specific claims um
being made about high cortisol and
talking about the signs people are
saying to look for the causes the
treatments and what we actually think
about those things yeah so we covered a
lot of them I think but I'm going to
name a few and you guys jump in
whereever you want um one thing that I
thought was really interesting or funny
is that when they talk about sleep
disturbances a lot of these are saying
very specifically waking up at 3:00 a.m.
this is why you're waking up at 3:00
a.m. and sometimes they'll they'll draw
or they'll have some kind of like
demonstration of the cortisol waking
curve and um and talk about 3:00 a.m. or
like the sign is you are waking up
between 2: and 4:00 a.m. and as far as I
can tell there is nothing specific to
the time that you wake up um although
people must be searching this a lot
because when I Google like why do I wake
up at 3:00 a.m. there are so many SEO
ready things ready to tell you exactly
why that is um fortunately one of them
or I think two of them were from the
Sleep foundation and they were like
there is nothing special about waking up
at 300 a.m. if you are waking up in the
night here are some of the Sleep issues
that you might want to look at and some
of the things you might want to do right
right we we stand a scientific
organization with good
SEO it's rarer than you might think yes
yeah yeah for for sure I love when they
have that so that when somebody Googles
that they're not getting you know like
some you know naturopath or whatever
they're getting like the Sleep
Foundation saying this is what you need
to know yeah um I also found out when I
did this that you can look up the
spiritual meaning of waking up at you
know insert time here so the spiritual
meaning of waking up at 3:00 a.m. that
is the witching hour or the devil's hour
it says I think this is like a Christian
website maybe um at 3: a.m. the veil
between the living and the dead becomes
thinner allowing free passage between
the two Dimensions interdimensional
creatures ghosts and demons creep into
the world of living creating chaos and
tormenting sleeping people wow um then
they quote they quote somebody who does
Mystic investigation saying that if you
wake up Legend has it that if you wake
up at exactly 3:00 a.m. for no reason in
a state of Terror then the devil has
paid you a visit literally or in your
dreams oh no um uh looking more of this
website I don't think it's a Christian
site I think it's just like a SEO like
woooo site yeah um their most recent
article is spiritual meanings of colors
blue yellow Violet red orange green
white
I personally love this allergies
spiritual meeting and causes that I
think is my favorite oh that's
amazing there's another one how to
recognize an angel in human form uh the
spiritual meaning of pain in different
body parts I I think that that's mostly
just you're injured in a particular body
part yeah really fun stuff like this
this seems to be a solid site you know I
just I just scrolled to the bottom of
the waking up at 3:00 a.m. part and it
says what about waking up up at 3:33
a.m. and that may be a message from your
guardian angel oh oh wow okay 33 minutes
the devil has left your guardian angel
is yeah so if you're waking up between 2
and 4:00 a.m. there are a lot of things
this could mean I didn't even get into
the 2 am ones so oh my gosh yeah to be
fair nobody on Tik Tok was saying this
specifically although I bet if I search
spiritual meaning of waking up at 3:00
a.m. on Tik Tok I will get a whole
another list of yeah yeah if not I'm
sure that's soon to come yeah that
that's another topic for another day
though I was going to mention um like
the cortisol belly and the moonface
thing I think we kind of covered that
about how it it it just kind of hooks
into all of the things people are
already saying on Tik Tok about weight
loss and I did find it interesting
sometimes you'll see somebody show their
cortisol transformation they'll show
show old pictures of themselves compared
to how they look now and like they just
lost weight yeah it's like they didn't
they didn't have like a particular
pathological appearance and then now
they have fixed that like it just looks
like a person who lost weight and if you
lose weight and you have good before
pictures that you can contrast with how
you look now you can make money on Tik
Tok selling anything that's so true
they're so viral oh man yeah and and
like the moonphase thing kind of gets
into they'll talk about like you have
swelling or you have lymphatic drainage
and you need to do gacha so gasa is um
it's a thing that has roots in like
Chinese medicine and you and it involves
like scraping like originally it would
be like scraping your skin hard enough
with like a a blunt object to get like
peti like little signs of bruising but
it's become a beauty Trend now so you
can buy like fancy you know you can buy
like a a fancy smooth Rock that's carved
into a certain shape and you do that on
your skin and it's supposed to like make
your face prettier if you do it every
night or something like that and so it's
just like extremely it's just like a
trendy Beauty thing like is it doing
anything I'm I'm not sure I'm not
convinced but but people are like
linking this in with the high cortisol
thing because like there you can sort of
like arguably make this connection
um and this relates to like the
lymphatic drainage lymphatic massage
which is also a thing there's another
corner of Tik Tok and you know
misinformation in general where people
talk about like detoxing yourself and if
you do massage that that moves your
lymph around then that's helping your
body to detox itself um I think you guys
got into that in the the vibration plate
episode right like you vibrate all the
lymph out of you no it stays in you but
like you vibrate it around move around
yeah um yeah I mentioned painful periods
are supposed to be one of the things
that uh that interacts with this whole
situation and so I was just curious I
went to AOG so the the oh I always get
mixed up what it stands for the American
college or Congress of Obstetricians and
gynecologists and I was like what did
they say about painful periods did they
mention anything about cortisol or about
any of these things and or and or about
like exercising on your period and like
no they they do have a whole page about
it go ahead and look it up you know if
you do have Painful periods they'll talk
about some things that can help and so
on and the literally the only thing it
says about exercise it does not say like
don't do this exercise during this week
it just uh has like one very brief
mention that it's good to do exercise
most days if you
can so I don't know these these
Obstetricians and gynecologists are just
not on board with the wisdom of Tik Tok
mhm um I mean there there are well-known
analgesic effects of exercise like I I
could see how that could be beneficial
or you know maybe the the acute cortisol
increase during exercise could help with
with other sensations of discomfort I
could believe that you know but also
like they're telling you to sometimes
they're telling you like don't do that
workout stay home and do yoga and like I
could see that feeling good you know
yeah so another one that comes up a lot
is this interaction between caffeine and
cortisol and I know I mentioned this to
you guys beforehand and you might have
some things to say about that but like
MH I actually first heard about like
this interaction in the the sense of
like a life hack that I don't know if
anybody I don't know if this was ever
validated in some way but some like idea
that some life hack dude had was like oh
well if you have a cortisol response
early in the morning wait to have your
coffee until like an hour or two later
after that's peaked and maybe it'll work
better then I have no idea if it works
better then I still drink my coffee like
shortly after I managed to get up and
make my coffee but there does seem to be
at least an assumption or a belief on a
lot of these social media things where
they're talking about cortisol where
they seem to imply that like drinking
coffee increases your cortisol or is bad
for you because cortisol or something
like that and the studies that I found
were mostly in rats and mostly using
extremely high doses um like 12 and a
half to 100 milligrams per kilogram so I
worked that out for myself it would be
like on the low end like 800 some
milligrams and on the high end like
seven gram I think oh my God for a 70
kilo person so it's like I don't I don't
think that's what they're talking about
I I think that is slightly different cuz
you you have to do like the human
equivalent dose conversion which forget
what it is for mice it's like divide by
8.3 or 16 one of the two can't remember
who cares whatever um yeah a lot of
caffeine that is regardless like a
shitload of caffeine it doesn't sound
like they're talking about the effect of
like one morning cup of coffee right
yeah um so like I I think this is again
one of those things where like there is
a kernel of truth because like the the
human research on caffeine like does
suggest that as a stimulant as with most
stimulants like you take it and you do
get in like in acute uh cortisol
response to it but one like even if
you're completely naive to the effects
of caffeine like if you have no
tolerance whatsoever the increase in
cortisol you get with caffeine you
isn't like particularly huge um and also
it seems to all go away within a week so
um something else I'll put in the show
notes is there was a study from 2008 by
lavalo and colleagues relatively large
study like a sample size of 48 men and
48 women so like 96 people in total um
or essentially they had people not use
caffeine at all for 5 days
and then they took either and it was a
crossover trial so like everyone
completed every condition there was like
a 5-day uh resensitization wash out like
between each um like arm of the study um
and all of these people basically had a
week where they used no caffeine as
their like quote unquote treatment 300
Mig or 600 migs um and in effect like on
the first day of a new C caffeine week
when they had not used caffeine for the
five preceding days they were
resensitized to it um on the first day
there was an increase in in cortisol uh
when they would take their caffeine dose
but then by the end of the week the
cortisol response like throughout the
day was the same as it was uh when they
didn't use caffeine at all so I mean
there are a couple interpretations you
could take away from that one is that
either a drinking coffee for just a week
completely burns out your adrenals such
that you don't have any cortisol
response anymore um and you're just
and that is definitely not the
case because like if you look further
into the data like essentially taking
caffeine didn't cause an elevation in
cortisol but like the normal dial
cortisol response and like waking
cortisol response and all of that was
still the same like like it was still
totally normal or like the other
interpretation is just that it's normal
habituation to caffeine consumption
which is what I think it is and like you
see that with um like caffeine I think
is pretty misunderstood cuz it's not
caffeine isn't a stimulant per se and
you do become habituated to a lot of
this like quote unquote like stimulatory
effects it's its main thing it does is
it's a central adenosine ant Agonist so
like not to get too far a field but like
adenosine is it it is something that
functions as a hormone and it tends to
have relaxing effects and uh there's
there's a part in your brain stem that
strongly influences like sleeping and
wakefulness uh it's your ascending
reticular activating formation and
essentially like caffeine binds to the
same receptors as a Denine would um but
it doesn't have a downstream effect and
so it's just kind of like clogging up
those those receptors and if it didn't
is ebound to those receptors it would
like make you sleepy and decrease the
wakefulness uh that you experience and
so like that's the main thing caffeine
does like when people say ah caffeine
helps me stay awake like it does
directly and mechanistically Via that
mechanism but like if someone is naive
to the effects of caffeine like if they
just never use it um for the first like
couple days you use caffeine you do get
an increase in epinephrine
norepinephrine cortisol like all of the
classical responses that you would see
to a like classical stimulant um but
those effects seem to mostly be
Downstream of like in acute dopaminergic
response that becomes like fully
attenuated within a couple days and then
within a couple days you don't see that
increase in epinephrine nor epinephrine
uh cortisol anymore so yeah I mean it it
is the case that if someone is naive to
the effects of caffeine they will see a
cortisol increase but if you use
caffeine consistently uh you stop seeing
a cortisol increase and that's that's
totally normal so there is something
that I've seen in a few places on Tik
Tok where they say okay if you drink
coffee at least have it after breakfast
is there any way you can think of that
that would like affect your cortisol or
affect any of these symptoms um I think
it's just people paring uh Andrew
huberman like he's he's the person that
I think has largely popularized that and
like as far as I can tell like his his
reasoning for it is essentially just
based on kind of like if a then B then C
then D sort of like mechanistic
reasoning but in terms of direct like
human experimental evidence on it
there's nothing so I don't know I my I
mean my perspective and like I think
that this is something that it's that it
would be easy to get like
too too concerned about potentially but
like
I do think that all else being equal
it's good to consume your caffeine as
early in the day as possible cuz like
caffeine has a pretty long halflife um
like depending on your your cyp1 A2
genotype like it it the halflife can
vary between individuals but it's
somewhere between like four and six
hours give or take so like if you have a
pretty hefty caffeine dose
even even like first thing when you wake
up you might still have and you go to
bed like 16 hours later to get 8 hours
of sleep you might still have like
that's four half lives so like 50% 25 12
so like you you could still have like 5
10% of the original caffeine you
consumed in your system and there was a
there was a meta regression on this
published earlier this year that I think
projected that like 2 to 300 milligrams
of caffeine consumption would still have
some sort of negative impact on your
sleep up to like 12 to 14 hours after
consumption I don't remember that for
sure like I I would need to look that up
but like yeah if if you're someone who
does kind of like the double shot first
thing in the morning I do think first
thing in the morning is the play um like
if if you delayed that by 2 or 3 hours I
it could still have like a tangible
impact on your sleep the ear the earlier
you consume it just the more Half Lives
you can get in like the more of it's out
of your system so
I kind of think in a vacuum like earlier
is better but that makes sense who knows
and the other thing I was going to say
about
caffeine is or like coffee intake first
thing in the morning is that like let's
grant them their premise all of it's
true like caffeine uh spikes your
cortisol that's bad whatever you don't
want that even if we granted that or or
like even if we granted that it does
spike your
cortisol um you would still have like an
uphill battle to a establish that it's
bad cuz like the the research on or at
least like the epidemiological research
on coffee intake and like health effects
and mortality effects is like relatively
positive um for the most part like
people who drink more coffee have lower
rates of cardiovascular disease and
lower like incidents of alause mortality
than people who consume the least amount
of coffee so so I don't know like even
if we Grant it and say oh it spikes your
cortisol like maybe it's worth it yeah
that would suggest that maybe it's a
good thing not a bad thing but I don't
Grant the premise because yeah you use
if you use caffeine you get addicted and
you use it every day like that's what we
all experience and uh yeah you you
habituate to it and after a week you
don't you don't have like a larger daily
area under the cortisol curve than you
would have if you just never used it in
the first place
so one thing that uh I don't have a lot
to say about but I am curious if you
have um thoughts on this is so a lot of
the the Tik toks about like what to do
about your high cortisol a lot of them
are nutritional or they're related to
supplements so of course everybody's
selling a supplement and they'll say
like foods to eat to lower your cortisol
and they'll list what looks to me like
just any just like a completely random
list of foods like foods that sound
healthy you know kale and what whatever
um and then kale always kale and
there'll be supplements and once again
like literally every supplement
sometimes they'll call out B vitamins
sometimes they'll call out magnesium
sometimes but it it it can be just about
everything and then they talk like we
said about adaptogens you can get a lot
of these like adrenal support
supplements a lot of them have
ashwaganda in it or whatever um and I'm
just curious about your thoughts on that
do you think there's any basis to this
do you think there's any anything that
would make sense to to do besides just
eating a normal healthy diet um I mean
maybe so I I think I think it's
plausible that like some of it could
have an effect
um I think with with ashwaganda in
particular it does have some like
angiolytic properties so like if you're
I mean I I think I think those two
things like dovetail pretty well like if
if you're a relatively anxious person
you will be the type of person who is
more likely to get caught in like
diagnose your own hormonal problems type
of Tik Tok content um and so yeah like I
I don't know directly about the effects
of ashwaganda on cortisol in particular
but like it does seem to be a mild
anxiolytic and if people uh like like
they shouldn't but if they associate
High cortisol with feeling anxious like
if that's if they think like oh these
are two bad things therefore they must
go together they might have the
perception that ashwagandha is lowering
their cortisol if it helps make them a
little bit less anxious and so I I kind
of think that's where that connection is
um and then like as we've talked about a
little bit already generally cortisol is
like the response to problems rather
than the cause of problems and so like
if
you are eating a generally bad diet and
like I I don't want to
I don't want to say anything that could
make it sound like I'm uh like that on
board with like inflammation gurus who
just try to tie everything to like
inflammation and like oh that's that's
what's causing all of your problems but
like eating a poor diet can like
increase basil levels of inflammation a
little bit um like lower dietary quality
is associated with like higher levels of
C reac active proteins like various cyto
like pro-inflammatory cyto il6 like all
of that stuff and so like in general if
you're in a just kind of worse Health
State um since cortisol also has like
anti-inflammatory properties uh I could
see it being plausible that if you have
a bad diet that might cause like a
lowgrade inflammatory response and you
therefore have higher cortisol levels as
as a result of that kind sense so if you
improve your dietary quality like just
eating good it's not like a A to B thing
like eating kale directly decreases
cortisol levels but like if it's a
generally healthier diet your basil
levels of inflammation go down a little
bit I could see cortisol levels coming
down a little bit uh kind of just to go
along with that um but once again it's
it's like a cause and effect type of
deal like if if your cortisol is
elevated due to a bad diet the problem
is the bad diet not the high
cortisol yeah that makes a lot of sense
but I could I could also be talking out
of my ass like that that is some that is
something that I would find plausible
but I don't know it to be the case I
mean if somebody were to follow these
recommendations that you know I see a
bunch on Tik Tok and they're they start
like eating more protein and they start
eating more vegetables and whatever like
it's it's it's hard to argue that that's
a bad thing right although I think I do
think if they start like spending a lot
of money on you know this influencer's
favorite adrenal support supplement like
a lot of these things are very expensive
and you know they'll they'll recommend
two or three of them that are each like
50 bucks for a month supply and that
could get real expensive real quick and
who knows if they're contaminated yeah
who knows what's in them yeah but most
of these treatments that they recommend
like you said seam you know just good
advice like better sleep hygiene eating
a little bit better but obviously if
somebody is actually having an issue
with
cortisol they need to go to the doctor
yeah you know if they're having an issue
with cortisol or if they're having an
issue with any of these symptoms that
you know are problematic right like um
this endocrinologist who you know had
the podcast about adrenal fatigue he was
like yeah a lot of the people who come
in complaining about night waking
because they think there's something
going on with their adrenal glands like
I I refer them for a sleep apnea test
because sometimes that might be the
thing that is going on yeah and so like
part of what really concerns me about
this and why I think it's like worth
talking about is because like the stuff
people say on social media about
cortisol is just like this I find it
like dangerous and problematic how how
they blend together things that are very
mild and common with things that are
very severe and like medical issues and
then like the fixes for them as well
right like they're like eat more protein
and also you know like do these other
things that are more drastic right and
so like to hear them tell it high
cortisol is both something that is so
significant that you must fix it and
fixing it will change your life but it's
also also minor enough that you don't
need to go to a doctor about it and you
can fix it yourself with Lifestyle
Changes yeah and like it can't be all of
those at the same time yep and so that's
where I think about like this article
about the the woman who had some of
these signs and like she was going to
doctors and doctors were saying like
well you're stressed out you're planning
a wedding you know and and then she was
still sick after the wedding and they're
like well are you in a happy marriage
are you sure and you know then it turned
out she had cancer you know that was
like causing this High cortisol and
everything so if do have um like
symptoms that are severe enough to be
impacting your life like seek medical
care for that right and like and and
like I always like to work instead of
like working backwards from what I think
I might have be like okay if my problems
are sleep related who do I talk to about
that or if my problems are related to
you know whatever it might be like who
do I talk to about that instead of
guessing at what the reason might be and
then trying to like seek out a specific
diagnosis yeah and like if you do think
you have a medical issue associated with
cortisol like you can go to your doctor
you can see an endocrinologist like they
study this and it's like fairly well
studied in terms of what kinds of tests
do we need to do um you know don't don't
put your health in the hands of somebody
who like calls himself a hormone coach
on Tik Tok yeah right
yeah something you alluded to is like
the the idea of like trying to take
ownership of your own health versus like
self- diagnosing and I think that those
are two very different things and one of
the things that frustrates me the most
is like when when people just get like
too out over their skis when discussing
like mechanisms and causes of things um
and the reason that I think that that's
problematic is like it it turns it turns
it into a story you know it's less just
like oh hey you're not feeling good here
are some things to try you know like
that is just that's just like
decontextualized advice and like it
might be responsible but it's not going
to be that sticky but then if you can
tell people you're feeling this way and
there's this hormone that does this
thing and it causes it like you can you
can tell I mean there's a plot there and
you get to make some of the connections
yourself right yeah but like that that I
think just sticks in the human mind
better um even though it's often like
very irresponsible and it is I think
kind of the switch that can be flipped
between yeah just like taking ownership
of your health and saying like oh man
like I feel really tired in the morning
all the time um like maybe I'll try to
do some general sleep hygiene stuff or
uh maybe I'll try to do like a little
bit of morning exercise to see if that
puts some pep in my step or uh I already
take a shower at night but like maybe
I'll just run a hot shower in the
morning to kind of like help perk me up
you know like there's there's any number
of things you could try that would be be
responsible and then like if it's really
bad you know like you really really
struggle to get out of bed you try a
couple things it doesn't work then
you're like okay like I I gave it my
best shot and I'll go to a doctor CU
like it seems to be beyond my realm to
to handle this and correct it versus
like self- diagnosing where you know
instead of saying hey I have this thing
what's some like Common Sense stuff I
can do to try to address it you go you
go down the rabbit hole saying oh like
I'm going to figure out what the cause
is the cause is high cortisol um and
then I'm going to make myself like
paranoid about all of the other things
that might be going on in my life and
and it's easy to like experience some
confirmation bias there cuz like once
you say oh I feel tired in the morning
because of high cortisol then you you
know you might see something like oh
like high cortisol also Calles bloating
and you're like oh I'm bloated sometimes
it's like well everyone's
bloated sometimes you know but like you
inter that is like further confirmation
that you have high cortisol and it's
like oh like sometimes I struggle
getting to sleep that's another high
cortisol thing it's like yeah but it's
also any number of other things you know
and so it it becomes easy to just like
not only self- diagnose but like further
and further reinforce the self-
diagnosis and then get caught in this
information space that says okay now
that you self- diagnosed it uh we know
what you need to do to correct it and
it's not go to a doctor you know so it's
it um I I think starts at a good place
of someone like trying to take more
ownership of their health and like not
overuse medical resources and go to the
doctor anytime something's like slightly
off but like it it leads you down a very
different Road where uh as you mentioned
like if someone does actually have a
legitimate medical problem uh caused by
high cortisol um they don't need
maximal self-efficacy that they can
treat it themselves you know like they
do need to go to the doctor and I think
that that is the danger in a lot of this
stuff like a lot of the recommendations
are ultimately relatively benign but
there's there's a lot of risk if you're
going the self- diagnosis route instead
of actually seeking real medical care if
there is something seriously wrong and
ultimately you as a lay person may not
be in the best position to know when
something is seriously wrong MH yeah and
I I think it's definitely like I can see
how it's it's like almost entertaining
to sort of like enter this rabbit hole
right because you you get this this
narrative like you're talking about like
oh I now I understand why I'm having
this oh and it explains this and it
explains this and it seems like things
are getting clearer but as you follow
this Rabbit Hole like it branches you
know there are 900 different things that
the people on Tik talk say that you
should do depending on who you listen to
or which video they're making that day
and so it ends up getting even more
confused refusing meanwhile taking you
away from you know like whatever
starting point you were at before you
went down the rabbit hole and so now you
have all of these things that you've
supposedly learned but you haven't
necessarily gotten any more clarity
about what you should actually do with
yourself yeah except buy more
supplements yeah always buy more
supplements yeah check out my discount
code Link in BIO yeah you you may not
wind up with less cortisol but you will
wind up with less money that's
true what are what are some of your just
kind of like General thoughts and and
takeaways at the end of this discussion
Beth so yeah I've been thinking about
that like what what can we take away
from this besides like go to the doctor
if you have a a real problem um and I I
think it's kind of meta but one of my
biggest takeaways as I've been scrolling
through all of this is how different
kinds of misinformation just like eat
each other up even things that totally
conflict with each other like adrenal
fatigue and high cortisol like all you
have to do is mention them in the same
video and now you've gained the powers
of everything people have heard about
adrenal fatigue and everything they've
ever heard about stress and you know and
then you can like add in people's
anxieties about weight loss and you make
this this sort of like this Kirby or
this Voltron that's like gained the
powers of all the different parts of it
um and and that has all these promises
about how you know a stack of
supplements can change your life or if
it's not this supplement it's going to
be this other thing and like I find this
like extra dangerous because if one of
those things doesn't make sense or you
try it and it doesn't work for you or
you find out that like oh that's not
real um all the other ones are still
there and this myth can just like keep
on going forever you know like I as I
was doing this I came across like a
Reddit for adrenal fatigue and so it
says like right up front like you know
adrenal fat fatigue is not you know
recognized diagnosis but then people
start talking about like I have HPA
access disregulation or dysfunction and
like you it it's just sort of like gets
to move its own gold poost as it goes
because it's like this conglomeration
made of everything
um and this I think also kind of ties
into like what Tik Tok is as a format
and like we said this applies to lots of
social media like T Tik Tok is like a
really good example to point at right
now um but like it's not the only one
that works this way and like ultimately
Tik Tok is just a collection of
performances that you get to scroll
through and for a lot of creators it
really seems to be like a game like you
see what other people are saying and
then say okay how can I make some like
this is what people talking about how
can I make my video my own video that
has my own spin on the thing that
everybody else is saying and like what
can I say that's going to get clicks um
and like make it in a way where you
think like more people will watch and
share yours than another one like as I
was scrolling through I found I found
like videos that were like duplicates of
each other but like with a different
person in it saying it in a different
way but like ultimately like making the
exact it looked like they were using the
same script and you can tell one person
saw the others and was like oh I can do
that better right and like maybe it's a
better video in terms of you know
engagement but you know you think you're
getting information and what you're
really doing is you're like watching
performances and providing clicks to
this algorithm you know these are not
necessarily people that have your health
as their goal here's a question for you
Beth um on Tik Tok the supplements being
recommended and and some of the
treatments that you would pay money for
um
how often did people have like affiliate
codes or discount codes always always
100% was it a relatively small number of
Brands that's a good question I I've not
done like a good
um like a real survey of this and I know
some Sometimes some of the other things
that I've looked at um you know not the
cortisol but some of the other ones like
I would definitely see the same ones
popping up over and over um that would
be really interesting to go through and
like study the number of Brands there is
definitely like affiliate link affiliate
marketing stuff going on here I am sure
there is MLM stuff behind some of it I
did not have the time to dig behind all
of this but um yeah I think you've got a
good Instinct there I I I suspect a lot
of it might be just like completely
synthetic cuz the thing about
supplements in particular is like they
have on on the worst of days for the
supplement industry they tend to have
great margins and on the best of days uh
and the best of days are when you can
repackage something that's relatively
cheap but sell it for a particular
purpose that people are concerned about
and therefore willing to pay money for
I.E B vitamins dirt cheap but
say oh now it's basically medicine uh
and you can mark it up instead of like
four times 10 times um now now you're in
a situation where you have a product
that has crazy margins and so so you can
reach out to influencers and say hey I'm
sure other uh supplement companies have
reached out to you but like I can give
you a better deal and also this is this
new thing like what whatever uh Health
concern people have been talking about
like that's already played out people
people have seen this content already um
but like no no one's talking about the
cortisol yet you know you can get in on
the ground floor or uh you know once it
gets going you can say hey look like the
I I'm this person from a supplement
company these five other influencers are
already promoting this product and like
making all of this money from it like do
you want to get in to um and like here
here's the ad copy it like when you said
a lot of the videos seem to be like
basically identical with just like
things presented slightly different ways
that was the first place my brain went
I'm like this is it might be monkey see
monkey do but I think it's mostly uh
affiliate marketing and people reading
like close variations of the same script
and a lot of this just being like
synthetically driven from the top down
oh see now now I want to go through and
like draw a family tree of these videos
like oh like like who who has the
supplements like what are the
supplements Linked In this one what are
the supplements Linked In this one I
would not be surprised at all if you're
absolutely right about that if if the
ones that have like very like very very
very similar sounding copy and like very
very similar sounding claims if they're
coming from the same supplement company
like I I almost promise you that's
what's happening yeah and then those are
going to be all the big influencers and
then like the smaller the people with
smaller follower counts are just going
to copy those and because they want to
seem like the big influencers they want
to be doing the trendy thing and then
yeah yeah it's just all the way down oh
that's fun that's fun Greg did you have
any takeaways you wanted to get into uh
I think I think Beth had one more yeah
yeah I just wanted to to mention that
like in terms of of your own Health like
just be thoughtful about distinguishing
between things that are so minor or so
mild that you can experiment with
Lifestyle Changes on your own to deal
with them versus issues that affect you
so much that you need professional
health which you know I which I think
like you you pretty much nailed um a
minute ago and just like go to go to a
person that specializes in the thing
that you think is wrong with you you
know like not a a hormone balance coach
you know and not you know and not like a
chiropractor if you think you a hormone
issue go to an endocrinologist like this
is a thing they exist like go and see
one of them yeah this is a this is a
specific thing this is a specific thing
that like I feel like there is like a
very good professional you can go to
whereas like that is not always the case
and people turn to kind of like more
holistic remedies because they don't
necessarily have a good doctor that's
going to listen to them that has good
tests to run that they can go to but
like this seems like one of those things
that you can just go to an
endocrinologist and they can just do a
couple tests and put you on some
medicine and they'll they'll know or run
some tests and say you don't need
medicine like yeah you might feel bad
but it's not because of your cortisol
that's not to say that all of these are
you know like super straightforward like
part of why you know this is sort of
like interesting and weird is like even
hormonal like things that we know are
hormonal are you know like complex right
because hormones have lots of effects on
our body and lots of things can affect
our hormones it's not like it's always
an open and shut case but you know give
yourself the best chance of getting it
solved by going to somebody who has
relevant expertise absolutely no I I
agree wholeheartedly with that I I do
wonder the extent to which that that is
kind of
like an indictment of our health care
System CU yeah this could just be that
I'm on like the American internet and it
could be the exact same Dynamics
everywhere but like I get the feeling
that a lot of this is like a very
particular American Neurosis or like
neurosis and it's not as big other
places and like I don't know like I I
wonder how much it is like getting
Medical Care is expensive and oftentimes
like very
depersonalizing um CU like the doctors
themselves are very overworked and they
might only be able to give you like five
or 10 minutes of time and so like you
you Al like quote unquote Alternative
Health stuff just feels more accessible
cuz like you can buy some supplements
for 50 bucks instead of like needing to
pay $50 just to step inside the doctor's
office and like $300 for some blood
tests and whatnot um or more if you
don't have insurance and also like you
you can at least get the feeling that
the people in the videos are like you
and care about you whereas like your
doctor probably does care about you but
they only have like five minutes to
express that before they before they
need to move on to the next patient
which isn't their preference like they
don't like that either but it's just
kind
ways how influences a lot of this I I
think that's a big part of it but also
having you know like talked to some
people who are into this stuff and you
know back back when goop did their first
big conference I went and I like talked
to some people about like just like oh
why are you interested in this stuff and
something that keeps coming up was just
people who either they or a family
member had like a medical issue and like
doctors couldn't help and you know some
of it is like issues that have with our
healthare system and some of it is
issues that any healthare system has but
a lot of is just like not everything is
a problem that's easy to solve you know
like some of them boiled down to like a
family member had cancer and that sucked
and they couldn't fix it and they died
and like not every problem is easily
solvable and even when you know what the
thing is not every solvable problem is
easily fixable and like that's sort of
the nature of medicine you know so far
in in history like may maybe someday
we'll have everything you know able to
be like fixed instantly I don't think so
but you know I think some of it is sort
of like an existential like you can't
fix everything doctors can't fix
everything but if I go to this
naturopath they'll at least talk to me
and make me feel better and then I'm
going to trust them to fix everything
and if they haven't you know maybe we
just haven't fixed it yet yeah yeah yeah
yeah that that makes sense that makes
sense I I yeah I think that kind of this
the snaky and rabbit hole of like
potential diagnoses and treatments like
I think that does a lot of work for uh
like naturopaths as well mhm cuz like
with with a doctor it's like oh hey you
think you have a cortisol issue let's
run these tests either you do here's a
drug uh and you know branching issue
from that like ah do you need something
else to help manage side effects do we
need to titrate dose whatever like it's
relatively like straightforward um or
it's just like oh no like you think
that's what your problem is we ran the
test it's not that uh do you want to do
just more broadspectrum testing or uh uh
do you want to leave and a lot of people
will leave whereas like with natural
health folks it's just like oh like it's
it's a lot more Loosey Goosey it's like
we're going to do a bunch of these like
free form tests that like you have a
billion degrees of freedom to interpret
however you wanton so like if you say ah
it's cortisol here's like five things we
can try first one didn't work Ah that's
fine on to the next one ah next one
didn't work ah on to the next one well
well okay none of these worked but based
on all of these just kind of nebulous
tests we did there's like 17 other
things it could be so like let's get on
to the next one and I think that that's
often like perceived as like caring and
holistic yeah it feels like they're on a
journey with you and you're navigating
it together versus a Doctor Who's just
like well if it's not that thing then
you know I don't know maybe take more of
that drug or maybe I'll refer you to
another specialist and you'll have to
start over yeah yeah and I I think that
it's I think that it's challenging cuz I
do think a lot of like Natural Health
folks are like they they believe
everything they say and they're very
well-intentioned like I I think that is
the majority of them but it's
also if I were a grifter that's exactly
how I would do it as well cuz it's it's
functionally you've given yourself the
longest leash possible to keep someone
on the hook for years and years and keep
draining them of money even if you never
help them cuz like you keep dangling the
carrot of Hope in front of them they
like oh there's there's always the next
thing we can
try yeah that's tough yeah I had a
couple takeaways from this as well um
one is that I think that it elucidates a
lot of the the problems that people have
with single Factor thinking so like most
of the things that people are
attributing to high cortisol are just
kind of like vague symptoms being
described that could have any number of
causes or that might just be completely
normal again like the tired in the
morning wired at night I keep coming
back to that cuz like I have an extreme
late chronotype and that's just my life
and my cortisol is normal and like I've
tried EV everything I can to like be
more of a morning person CU like the
world is built for mourning people but
like I can't you know and there are
people like me and it's normal and it's
annoying but it's fine and like I it
doesn't need to be like interpreted as
as high cortisol causing that um yeah
like vague symptoms that could be caused
by any number of things or are
completely normal and there's a desire
by a lot of these folks just to chalk it
all up to cortisol and I think that
that's like a natural human thing to do
because it helps like simplify a problem
which gives people a greater sense of
agency like it gives you the idea that
there's a lot of stuff going on in your
life that you don't like and a lot of
things that are making you feel bad and
there is there is a single cause and if
you can address that one thing
everything else will go away um and I
think that that's inherently alluring to
folks because it's just simply easier
than making like really really
significant lifestyle changes to take a
more broadspectrum approach to address a
lot of problems that you might be
experiencing and then like to step out
even further I think that it's
emblematic of something that's like
really common in American culture in
particular although I assume that it's
the case other places as well and that's
the idea of like substituting in uh like
Notions of like personal responsibility
instead of looking for like Collective
or systemic or systematic solutions to
things like one of the things that
jumped out to me both in like reading
about cortisol in general and and going
through the content of this episode is
that a lot of the things that people
attribute to high cortisol just sound
like symptoms of General fatigue and
burnout and also like if it is a
cortisol thing like if if these people
are going through life with high
cortisol and that is truly causing all
of these problems for them uh their
cortisol might be Skyhigh because
they're so fatigued and stressed and
burnt out um due to everything else
going on in their life again like
switching cause and effect just like
stuff in your life sucks and that's
what's making your cortisol high and
making you feel bad versus high cortisol
being the cause of the
problems I think that that's like an
easier way to look at it like framing it
through the lens of personal
responsibility like oh you have high
cortisol that is your problem and it is
therefore incumbent upon you to fix it
to to make yourself feel better um and I
think it's also generally more
profitable cuz uh instead of saying like
hey there's a lot of just general stuff
that's bad and uh we might have to
invest money collectively to fix those
things instead you can say Hey you have
this problem and you can pay me money
and buy a product that will fix it you
know uh buy some supplements buy some
blue light blocking glasses come to my
like somatic Treatment Center um and so
yeah like that's both both easier and
more profitable than doing things like
you know if if
you're if you're like fatigued and
stressed and burnout because you're
living in like a precarious financial
situation like the majority of Americans
are like what's the statistic like 60%
of people are one paycheck away from
from getting put on the streets um or
like your your job sucks cuz like your
workplace isn't organized and you have
no labor protections and you work in a
at will employment state so you might
just be canned anytime um or like
you're in a bad relationship and have
like no social support because a lot of
like social systems have broken down and
uh you know you don't have that much
free time to develop a robust friend
group and you had to move three hours
away to find a job instead of being able
to stay close to family and your support
network like there there there are a lot
of things that like could be making you
feel shitty and like the solutions to
those problems are tough like you know
organizing for better working conditions
and better wages like agitating and
organizing for like a more robust social
safety net so you don't feel like the
the gripping anxiety of just like if you
have one bad day on the job and get
fired like you're a month from
now if you can't find something else um
you know like advocating for like better
urban planning so there are like more
and better public spaces for like being
social and like having meaningful
connections with people in real life
like a l a lot of those things would
make people feel better and
that's yeah harder and less profitable
than just saying like hey buy some be
vitamins you know yeah and and a lot of
these you know like they'll say like
well eat your kale and go for walks and
whatever and it's like to some extent
like that is itself aspirational like
how many people have a place where they
can easily and safely go for a walk in
the morning or whatever hour they want
how many people are are getting like are
buying all of these supplements and have
the money to buy all these supplements
and stuff and like yeah yeah no and I
totally agree with all that all this we
live in like a capitalist hellscape that
is making our lives most of us making
our lives worse and we do not have a lot
of power to change that yeah yeah I mean
it's uh I I mean I mean I should I
should not be such a downer we should
take upon ourselves the power that we do
have to change that absolutely un
unionize your workplace if you don't
know how to do that get in touch with me
I'll put you in touch with somebody but
yeah but it sucks yeah so yeah that
that's not a particularly happy note to
close on but I I do think that
there's I I I I feel like I would be
doing a disservice by not mentioning
that cuz like cortisol stress hey why
are people stressed like H there's
there's a lot of stuff that you can't
fix by taking a pill or tapping on your
forehead yeah and like there's a lot of
research on like the effects of stress
on on health you know like social
determinance of health and and things
that like really do have you know a
major effect poverty racism like these
things have huge effects on your health
maybe some of that's mediated by
cortisol you know um but yeah so um yeah
yeah buy my supplements that'll help all
right so yeah the the link to so most
most of these adrenal support
supplements are but Beth is
actually launching a line of legit
adrenal support supplements uh use code
SPS pot at checkout link will be in the
descript no complete joke if my boss is
listening this is a joke
okay seriously uh thanks so much for
coming on this this was a blast thank
you so much for having me are there any
closing thoughts you would like to leave
the listeners with or tell people where
they can find you well that was going to
be my next question Sor okay fine let me
let me Lind Lindsay is doing the outro
have fun yeah so I'll skip to that one
um because I think I said everything I
wanted to say um so uh you can find me
at Beth skw on all the social medias I
think I do have a Tik Tok I have exactly
one video and it's a very silly one and
um and I'm on Instagram for my lifting
stuff but most of what I do is I write
for life haacker so you can go to
lifehacker.com and uh read all our stuff
and uh enjoy thanks so much Beth thanks
Beth thank you so
[Music]
much
he